This is the shill argument. Okay. If you were just a total chill,
this is the argument you'd make, right? Oh. Uh, >> I'm
responding exactly to what you just >> No, you're not.
I don't think you do. Do you know what an argument? >> They're
both They're both shaking their >> Are you not What are
you not following? >> Do you know what an argument is?
I'm just curious. >> I am making the argument that the
response that we're seeing right now is >> Can you shut
the [__] up for 5 seconds? Seriously, I'm making
the argument that the what we're seeing right now with the crazy
level of harass >> Sir,
do you know what an argument is? Sir, sir, >> ask me is
the reason why they would have that kind of a protection mechanism
in the in the in the contract >> yours. Okay. Jesus Christ.
>> Every time they ask me I I want to point out to you
that Taylor Loren is so correct here that Destiny sat there like
a unic on his own stream and just let Taylor condescend to him
the whole time. Well, don't you think it's like a little weird
that you did that? I understand why you're confused, Destiny.
I understand that you're a little confused. It's okay. I'll explain
it to you. actual Unix stream.
Here's how we tap into the average man. Okay, like our relevant
said he he basically, you know, psychologically constructed in
his own mind the average person. Okay, but here's how I tap into
the average man. Warren Smith. I can't think of somebody more
socially adept than Warren Smith. Okay, 9minute video. David
Pacman panics and exposes his own corruption in dark money scandal.
Let's check it out. Let's see what Warren has to say. >> Has
been exposed working with the Chorus Project, which has been
paying him $8,000 a month. >> It's in the second paragraph.
>> Okay, we've already [__] up
I don't believe Pac-Man was getting paid, but god damn it. Or
I didn't think he was. Maybe he is. >> It mandated extensive
secrecy about disclosing their payments and had restrictions
on what sort of political content creators could produce.
That means they're dictating your content directly in the contract.
>> David Pacman has been screaming. Uh it's
there's two sides to this to how they dictate content. Okay.
And they they work with each other. So it's just it's a little
weird. Okay? Let me explain it. They sponsor only it's the weirdest
I've ever seen. Could you imagine Nike sponsoring Michael Jordan
and then just saying, "Listen, you you can promote this as much
as you want, just never in the context of you being a basketball
star. Listen, we just want you, Michael, to like work on, you
know, your uh your your like business understanding, your business
acua. Okay? You go take an NBA or something. This is a grant,
so you can take an NBA. We're going to pay you millions of dollars.
All right? And we want you to get your your your NBA. Um it's
not for basketball. It's like that what that doesn't that doesn't
make any sense. You're sponsoring political creators who make
only political content.
essentially only political content, but you're but you don't
want your name to be associated with their political content.
That but also if you stop making b playing basketball, your contract
is over. Yeah. It's like it's like that in and of itself is already
just bizarre. Okay.
I don't think people know the context of this. People know the
context of Chorus. We've been talking about the Chorus drama
for a couple days. I think if you're here, you know about Chorus.
Okay. Chorus is a
liberal aligned
content creator uh like a content creator networking program
that built up that spun up an incubator program where they're
paying people to
basically like they're paying to promote those people. They're
paying to make sure those people are financially secure so they
can create content, right? That's what they were doing. And they
they got like a dark money group involved to pay those people
out. It's like not necessarily a horrible thing, but some of
the stuff where they restrict whether or not you can disclose
is a little it's a little concerning. It's a little confusing.
All right, we're going to watch a lot more stuff that has to
do has to do with this. It's an attempt at liberal TPUSA. It's
not quite an attempt at liberal TPUSA.
Um, there are like some slight differences. I think I think maybe
if they could become that that would be good, but it's not quite
that. Okay. Chorus is a nonpartisan pro-democracy group. Haha.
Aha. Aha.
trying to respond. He came out with a video where he tries to
justify
>> Since this article came out, I've heard from a bunch
of you, David, did you sell out? David is the DNC telling you
what to say. How could you do this to us? But where it gets really
interesting is that the following day, he openly admits that
he has been working directly for politicians. The hypocrisy here
is staggering. All right. I was not even going to talk about
this. Of course, you weren't. You were getting paid not to talk
about it. >> I was named in an article in Wired yesterday.
And the article is about a so-called dark money group. >> It's
not supposed dark money group. It is. Had this article not come
out, do you think David Pacman would have ever revealed this?
>> And I was not even going to Well, I think Pac-Man would
have talked about being a part of Chorus. Sure. But he I I don't
think I don't think most of these creators were ever going to
disclose that they're being paid by Chorus. I just don't think
that didn't happen before. I don't think any of them would have
done it unless this article was coming out. And in fact, I believe
that if if some of them did like in the days before, I would
imagine that it was in reaction to the article. If they had,
I don't I don't believe they did. Right. Thought Warren Smith
was on Destiny's side. No, Warren Smith's like a right-wing grifter
like a like a Elon Musk affiliated grifter. >> They give
this the time of day. >> Yeah. Right. This is one of the
biggest mistakes, if not the biggest mistake he's ever made.
>> Other creators, like a Twitch streamer named Hassan
[__] were covering this in ways that don't reflect
the reality of the situation and are perpetuating falsehoods
about what is and isn't going >> Okay, tell us what is
false. Now, the most important thing to say is that the idea
behind this group is exactly what I've been advocating for for
years. David Pacman would probably claim that he wants to get
money out of politics. Then he turns around and engages in exactly
that, claiming this is what he wants to happen. >> It's
for years I've been saying the left needs to organize independent
media in the way that the right has been doing. >> Yeah.
The problem is that the right has not been doing it. this way.
There is no centralized network on YouTube. It's messy. Uh Warren
just would never educate himself on this at all. Like if the
right I I don't know exactly how TPUSA does their like um like
their affiliates and I don't know how they have that whole thing
set up. I don't know. But I would just imagine that the right
does a lot of this in general like uh funding people through
what would you call it? Like like some groups just funding creators
to to spread messaging, right? I I just I have to imagine they
do the same thing cuz the left's trying to catch up to something.
What is it that they're trying to catch up to? >> Because
it is organic. Feuds erupt because there's not agreements preventing
us from talking about what we want to talk about. >> The
left needs to fund independent creators the way that the right
does. The right has won even arguably presidential elections
because they're organized with regard to online and independent
media.
Like I do think that this is just that the big independent media
figures who endorse Trump I don't believe were paid to do so.
I don't I don't believe so. I I've never seen any any evidence
of that that like Joe Rogan's getting paid to support Trump.
>> They're us. We've been so behind. But it works because
it's decentralized. >> And this kind of support for creators
is exactly what I've been advocating for. He's trying to paint
the picture as though this is it's not sketchy. No, I've been
openly calling for this. >> Now, the article is riddled
with inaccuracies and they're not minor inaccuracies.
First and foremost,
this group has nothing to do with the DNC. >> It's an organization.
>> Just to be clear, the article never claims that the
group is controlled by the DNC.
I think it says push Democrat messaging, push party line, but
it doesn't actually talk about the DNC. You could say the DNC
and the Democratic Party are the same. I don't even hate that
idea. Like you could say they're the same thing, but specifically
the CL riddled with inaccuracies and then you like kind of miss
on the first one. It's >> That allows very wealthy individuals
to be able to buy influence and to prevent anyone from revealing
it. They spent $400 million to sway the election in 2020. I don't
care if you have official ties to the DNC. >> At its base,
the group has nothing to do with the DNC period. No, but Charlie
Kirk, Ben Shapiro, people like that were funded by the Wilks
brothers and Ko. Yes, but Matt NLT, that's very, very, very different.
Right. I think that's incredibly different. And I don't think
most people to me that's like way more obvious. If those people
want to invest in some media company because of a profit incentive,
that makes total sense to me. I understand that. That's not really
dark money. That's like them doing like seed funding for a for-profit
venture. If you take your talking points, your political talking
points from a purely for-profit venture, like you probably have
to be concerned. That's not like a an actual journalistic outlet.
Like, they have to have some journalism backbone to them, or
else you're just kind of up, right? I I would say in general,
if you took all your political news from one place that was a
for-profit venture like that, you could say that it's uh it's
bad or something.
But um but it's just different than what Chorus was trying to
do where they're not trying to disclose the money. They're just
trying to like fund small creators like independent ones. I would
not call the in the Daily Wire independent media. I don't think
that's I don't really think that's true.
Uh
what else did you say? Turning point USA. Turning Point USA and
the Daily Wire to me are like actual institutional media. Like
I think they're new institutional media, but I look at them as
institutional media in a lot of ways. Prageru isn't Prageru is
is probably sketchy.
Prageru is probably sketchy. Yes. Turning Point also sketchy.
But yeah, the the Daily Wire is something where I I just I see
it as like a different animal entirely. And and realistically,
if people were going to fund like a left-wing network like that,
I think that'd be good, right? You're going to fund some some
like liberal equivalent. Well, hold on. That's just Midas touch,
right? Isn't that just
Midas touch?
That Yeah, I I'm pretty sure we got that already. The Midas slot
>> That's just such a false way to spin that though. Number
two, I do not get clearance for anything I say. >> Nonsense.
Because it's spelled out right there in the contract. You cannot
contradict specific narratives. Why do >> No, it's not.
Uh-oh.
Warren Smith.
Warren Smith with very poor reading comprehension.
Uh-oh. >> You have to meet for what is it? Regular advocacy
trainings and daily messaging check-ins. I >> okay that
to me people don't talk about that enough. The only response
I've seen from anybody debating on the pro chorus side on that
one is
uh you don't know what's being said in those meetings.
Uh what a riveting what a riveting endorsement. You don't know
what's being said in those meetings.
No. I would kind of assume personally that those meetings might
be used to push points that would align with the people funding
the program. No. Isn't that the most obvious thing that would
happen? Daily messaging check-ins? What do you mean messaging
>> I do not run interview questions by anyone at Chorus.
I don't tell Chorus when I'm going to be doing an interview.
Not a single segment I have done, not a single question I've
ever asked a guest has anything to do with chorus. But where
it gets really interesting is that the following day, Pacman
made a video seemingly unrelated. He openly admits >> Oh,
did we watch the unrelated video? I watched it personally, but
uh it's not really unrelated. It was like him seething about
how he couldn't get Camala Harris or like any other big politician.
Oh, no. Seething about how he couldn't get like a senator on
his program. Like he basically was like, "Oh, they gave me an
email that goes to nothing." And he was like seething about >> He
has been working directly for
>> I'm not going to name names here. Um but I I >> That's
not what he said. more awards.
That's not He didn't say he's working directly for politicians.
He was like, "Oh, I think like you're it's like somebody who's
running in a contested primary reached out to David Pacman cuz
he'd had like the person who would run who who would who's the
incumbent, he'd had them on his show." So, the challenger went
to David Pacman and said, "Hey, I know you have a connection
to this guy. I'd love to debate him. Would you like to moderate
a debate? If you could get that, I'd be willing to debate. Be
cool for everybody." Right? >> That's I think the story
here. >> To tell you the story. there is um an elected
official uh house or senate who um we have been in touch with
on the show off and on over the years and this individual's challengers
have been reaching out to me. I would like your endorsement or
at minimum I would like to be on your show. So he tries to call
up the politician to tell him that hey man your competitors want
to come on my show. How would you like me to respond to this?
So, I reach out to the office of this elected official and I
say, "Hey, just a reminder, David Pacman,
you've done the show off and on over the years. We have a relationship.
uh I am trying to get in touch to figure out what is going on
and I want to hear it from you before making any decisions about
our coverage so that I ensure that our coverage is calibrated
to is this an open seat or is this a an incumbent who's being
challenged just want to touch base >> and his big problem
is well they transferred me to this this other email address
or this other number and they simply say for any campaign questions
email info at
a different website. They did not treat me like an important
>> That is what he's seeing about that he got handed off,
right? That he didn't get, you know, he feels like I should have
some influence here. It's it it was very weird the the timing
of these videos.
Yeah, it was very bizarre that he's like seething about not getting
these connections while talking about chorus. I know we will
never ever ever hear back and this is the fundamental problem.
That sort of way of dealing with independent media is how all
of us will end up going screw this elected official. Let's endorse
the challenger. Let's fundra for the challenger. Let's th this
is exactly the problem that we are talking about. And so I reached
out to my contacts on the hill and I said, >> that's not
how you're going to be able to buy the result you want. >> This
is exactly what Dude, he's Dude, Warren Warren is like struggling
so hard to not be wrong about every single thing he says throughout
this entire video. This is like so insane how wrong he is about
every element of this. And I I haven't defended Pac-Man in like
any sense, but Warren is proving that he is like a level above
David Pacman in terms of being a uninformed.
Jesus Christ, we can't buy the results you want that way. David,
>> what I thought we were trying to fix. >> He admits
going to the White House, meeting with the president. >> When
we went and met with the Biden administration and met with people
from the House and met with people from the Senate in DC, >> just
indicates the level of cooperation and direct communication he
has been having with politicians. Should I allow them on the
show because they're your competitors? So, he contradicts himself.
>> There are no restrictions of any kind on my content.
>> And of course, he's going to say this. That's what they're
paying you to say,
Um, no. I don't think it has restrictions on the content. I don't
think that's how this thing works. I think if they had actual
explicit restrictions in the content, they'd be Taylor Loren's
article would be like, "Hey, this would be like the FEC's opening
salvo for a lawsuit or or to find these people majorly, right?
They there's they can't do explicit restrictions on content.
You cannot do >> I've never covered a story because Chorus
suggested I do it. I've never not covered a story because Chorus
suggested I not do it." The >> contract contradicts this
in black and white. There is >> Read the part of the contract
that contradicts that, Warren. Oh boy. Oh boy. Warren. >> No
relationship of any kind. >> Well, then why accept the
$8,000?
>> Dude, also the idea that David Pacman
making like probably at least six figures a month, if not like
like not just a hundred, but he probably makes like two $300,000
a month, right? I would imagine. He's got like a couple employees.
I wouldn't be shocked if he makes two $200 or $3,000 a month
or sorry two or $300,000
a month.
And
just the the idea that he would take $8,000 for for something
that could apply any restrictions to his content is >> So
what does Chorus do? >> Pacman is a mentor. He has >> technical
training. >> I think they did screw up in the article.
I think they did say Pac-Man was taking money. He was a part
of the cohort. I think they said that. Somebody said that somewhere.
Okay.
But Pac-Man obviously like he makes too much money to be a part
of those cohorts. It would be stupid for him to be there. He's
a mentor. >> How to produce content, how to make your operation
more efficient. >> So they're paying you $8,000 a month
to help you produce content. It's usually it's the other way
around. So fbombs, and I realize it says this in the contract.
I fully believe that if you ask Chorus, sorry, if you don't check
with Chorus and you just don't say you're associated with them,
you can do whatever content you want and they will not stop you.
They're they're going for people who are mostly demoligned, but
they will not stop you from doing any content you want. They'll
just keep paying you because that's the whole point of like their
funding structure is they're going to miss and they don't care
about that, right? That there is no negative there is no negative
filtering they're doing. They're not doing any, you know, d
uh what you call it, subtraction from their organization based
on content.
If they if they missed, if they picked the wrong person to fund,
they just eat that because doing something negative to them,
stopping them, right,
would would put you at risk of like being, you know, some sort
of uh politically partisan group, which I think they're not allowed
to do. Basically get you accused of being partisan. Pac-Man got
noted for saying the article was debunked. Let's
Did he really? That'd be awesome. After what Reesewired hit piece
now fully debunked, no retractions or corrections were issued
for this story. It was not debunked.
Let's go. Deepack getting uh getting it from all sides. >> Take
a small shop of one, two, or three people and put content out
on multiple platforms the way I've been doing successfully for
decades. >> This isn't just about teaching people how to
make thumbnails. I mean, how watch how he spins this. They set
up mentorship relationships between larger creators like me and
small upandcoming creators who are looking to do content, which
is something I've said for years we need to be doing. >> If
it's something that you've been calling for for years and you
feel passionately about, why don't you do it for free? Why do
you need them to pay you $8,000?
>> I I believe he is I believe he is doing it for free.
I
Warren just always baffles me with how little research or how
much he tries to be informed on anything. Warren just [__]
up like every aspect of every story. It's incredible. His his
capacity to do this is unbounded.
>> They do advocacy trainings. They do media trainings.
How do you deal with
adversarial media? >> Well, now he has this whole network
to help him spin the situation. He's spelling it out right here.
>> They do legal training so we understand how is the right-wing
machine potentially going to come after us? How do you organize
your business to be protected? That's what they do. >> Think
about the subtext here. He's admitting they are behind his response.
If this was a group or an organization,
that's actually bordering on insight there from from Warren Smith.
Yes, they've they've told me how to respond to the right-wing
attacking me over the a little bit. That's kind of funny. I think
that's also about setting up an LLC, right? That's something
they said they do. They have a training on like setting up an
LLC. So your identity is >> That required me to get permission
before saying things or fed me talking points or told me David
talk about this and not about that or anything like that. I would
never
by the way this all this to say, okay, David Pacman's like blatant
but like coded shilling for Israel, his his like blatant bias
on that issue. I think I firmly believe that comes entirely from
himself. Okay. What is it? IPAC. AP pack. IPAC. I don't even
know how you say that. I'm a I'm a guy who's been a political
influencer for like a decade and I don't know how you say APAC.
What is it? IPAC.
A rac
How would I know? How would I know? Come on, man. >> Part
of it. Period. Yet the video you made right after this, you do
exactly >> Yeah, we've covered we've covered this Matt
Slice. It's good. >> This is just a subsidy that
really affects your coverage that you're literally not allowed
to disclose. It's actually taking creators under their wings
so they know how to properly post thumbnails and descriptions
that are going to get engagement. This is just about best practices.
And I would love somebody to give me a $8,000 a month retainer
to teach me about how to do thumbnails. You have the ability
to run. >> By the way, I have no doubt that part of their
mission was to do these mentorship relationships where even like
the the mentors could benefit from it, right? Like if you guys
are unaware, I believe Pacman mentored Luke Beasley. Luke Beasley
didn't quite mentor, but but like there was a relationship where
Luke Beasley got help from Josiah early on when Josiah was doing
work, right? They worked on together and then Josiah spun up
his channel from like based on I I assume a significant amount
of learning from Luke Beasley. Luke Beasley similarly a lot of
learning from David Pacman, right? I have no doubt that they
want to like scale out that model that has led to them getting
other successful content creators going.
But that that doesn't answer any of the negative aspects of the
article, right? You can have noble intentions for your organization
and also do in uh ignoble ignoble things. Is that ignoble >> on
your business, how you want to run it. If you want to take money
from them, like fine. It's don't be surprised when the audience
reflects reality and this implodes because the
>> dude Warren Warren is such a Warren's a special guy.
Okay. Warren's a big special guy. He's a very special dude. All right.
Very special guy.
Very, very special guy. Okay.
I was thinking about checking this out. I don't know how much
I want to go like deep on chorus another day, but basically there's
this What is this? This is like Leftist Mafia or something. I
think this is the name of the podcast. Leftist Mafia. And it's
got Matt Binder and
uh a progressive brat was on here. If you don't remember, Taylor
Loren let us know that progressive brat was in a group chat about
like slandering Taylor Loren.
So there's progressive brat went on this uh this podcast started
on Taylor as well. Let's take a look. Ariana Jasmine talks about
her experience with Taylor Loren. Alleges that Taylor accused
her of scamming with Chorus and changed her OG story. Accused
her of scamming with Chorus and changed her OG story angle when
submitting to Wired. First article Taylor wrote about Chorus.
Chorus taking advantage of creators scamming. Oh, wait. But wasn't
that actually the case? Weren't they actually scamming creators?
Isn't that an actual article she wrote? Like the article where
they were
representing that they they they were saying we represent these
creators. They had no formal relationship with them. I think
they did actually scam some creators technically.
They were totally presenting themselves as like partners and
and put the the partnership photo with somebody they'd never
like had any formal relationship with on their donation page.
That's pretty bad, man. The context of this conversation was
that the first article that Taylor wrote about Chorus, it was
when it had first launched and she was making an argument that
Chorus was taking advantage of creators.
Her whole, it was on her, I don't know, user mag or whatever.
And she had essentially made this argument that um Chorus was
only taking people's money to scam people. That was her whole
entire argument. Which is why when I saw the wired piece, I was
like, which one is it? Are they scamming people or are they paying
people? I I I I don't know. The angle completely switched when
it went to Wired. Completely.
>> They're totally different stories. They're they're literally
entirely separate stories. Damn. You know, this is this is what's
up sometimes, guys. I say that nobody could possibly have like
a worse or less informed opinion than Warren Smith. And then
immediately I got egg on my face. Okay, I got egg on my face.
Instantly, Ariana Jasmine comes in and she's like, "You think
Warren's a take a look at me? Take a look at me." >> Um,
and so she basically she basically alleged that I was in support
of creators getting scammed, which was not true. She said, "But
again, good luck sighting with the rich men exploiting these
young women and using their images non-conensually. Apparently,
Chorus had put people's images on their website. That was non-consensual."
That was her reporting. I hope it works out wonderfully for you.
I'll be sure, by the way, to make it clear in my follow-up pieces
that creators such as yourself are standing with this behavior
since you're eager to make it clear where you stand. >> Think
we I feel like we have three simps on this panel. No, wrong.
Matt Binder would never simp. Okay, this Matt Bender
this guy's a true cold-blooded incel. Okay, I believe he's married,
but don't take don't take that as like a an indicator of anything,
okay? It's like a beard for his his incel relationship with himself.
>> And I said everything I said hold on. I said everything
that I said is off the record and if you put it in your article
you will hear from my lawyer because we were having a normal
conversation. She said nope sorry that's not how off the record
works and your lawyer can explain that to you. I said I don't
Ruben donated
Ruben donut. This >> is where disharmony grows >> using
anything I said in any of your articles. I just don't I'm sorry.
It doesn't matter because you said it on the record. You said
you and these quote other creators on the left end quote are
so eager to align yourselves with an exploitive man taking money
from young female creators and using their images without their
consent. I said, "No, I didn't. Everything I said is off the
record." She said, "Nope, it's not. I'm sorry. Nope, it's not.
Sorry. Off the record is a two-way agreement. I absolutely would
never grant someone off thereord status to defend a man exploiting
young creators." I'm glad I'm glad you I'm glad I I you're giving
this to us and I'm glad I I went for it because she's both right
and wrong. Number one, I think it's inappropriate >> using
your power.
>> H
Ariana Jasmine does does not like hearing that she's possibly
wrong on something. You see her just grab that mic. Do you see
that? Oh my goodness. >> I'm glad I I went for it because
she >> He didn't even He softened it, too. You're both
right and wrong. Or she's both right and wrong. both right and
wrong. Number one, I think it's
>> dude. That poor mic. That mic is getting the kung fu
grip right there. That's >> But I I went for it cuz she's
both right and wrong. Number one, I think it's >> Using
your power to threaten people. >> No, hold on. No, hold
on. I think she's inappropriate for the way she talked to you.
Without a doubt, that's as someone reaching out as a journalist.
She added um some color commentary that she was 100% wrong. And
I think that's very inappropriate. I'm actually surprised she
did that. Second of all though, >> she is I'm so sorry
not to pick you up. I am not the only creator that she's spoken
to this way. She has spoken to a slew of creators. She has gone
off on she has >> Matt's going to disagree with her on
the actual consequential part of the argument though, right?
Actual consequential part of the argument, he's just going to
be like, "No, no, no. As a journalist, yeah, if you you got to
get off the record like from the start, you start by saying off
the record." Otherwise, you're talking to a journalist. You're
talking to somebody who reports stories for a living. If you're
gonna if you're going to yap to them without saying this has
to be off the record. Everybody knows that. Who hasn't who's
not watched House of Cards? Can you be in politics and not have
seen the first season of House of Cards,
right? Every time a a weird questions asked, they go, "Wait,
this is off the record, right?" They confirm it even like every
single drama about politics, they're talking to a reporter, they
go, "Wait, this is off the record, right? Wait, this is off the
record." Just confirming it. How do you not know that? She has
spoken to a slew of creators. She has gone off on them. She has
threatened their power on them. I'm not the only person. >> Uh
Ariana was doing some weird [__] Okay, of course
we have we have all the shills. All the shills in the replies.
>> The content of this conversation was >> Oh, hold
on. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Wave been thoroughly embarrassing
himself throughout this saga. This has honestly been a huge We'll
be by the way, we'll probably be getting to his panel. Okay,
this panel he tried sweeping so hard. He It was just like a What
was it? It was supposed to be 3v3, but it was like 4v3, right?
He tried sweeping so hard for Hutch and And soy pill. Soy pill.
Soy pill. Whatever the [__] is this? The chick that
has a mole in the VC in the GC. Uh Taylor Lens does has a mole
in their GC. Yeah.
Has Wick said anything about the doxing yet? Almost certainly
something. I would guess this was uh this has honestly been a
huge credibility hit to Wired for working with Taylor. This whole
thing seems like Taylor Taylor's been working backwards to try
and discredit Chorus in any way she can. Not exactly good journalistic
journalistic ethics at play here.
Uh, she wrote a different article in Chorus that I don't think
has been factually disputed either.
So, I don't know. I don't know what we're talking about here.
Wired is complicit and I honestly do not trust any editors or
lawyers they use who are willing to look past Taylor's bias,
editorializing, and lack of professionalism to platform her in
a mainstream publication. They must be sick offense themselves
if they associate with this. Well, at least these people are
attacking Wired directly now, right? That's what I was saying
before is don't be attack the institution. Attack the journalistic
institution. Show yourself to be blue maga. Okay? Don't don't
beat around the bush. Be who you are. Be that with your whole
chest. Okay? As Lewis Rossman says, if you're going to be a [__]
be the whole [__] Okay? Don't be half a [__]
If you're going to be a [__] be the whole [__]
Thank you. Thank you, Wick. Thank you. Okay, Taylor Loren responded
to this. Okay, Taylor Loren responded. I'll read her response
and then I I might check out the the panel for a little bit.
Give me a second. Ariana Jasmine continues to lie about my reporting
on Chorus. I spoke to a slew of creators for my Wirepiece. Who
do you think leaked me all the source material? Continually lying
about me and my work because you personally don't like me is
so revealing. After my first story on chorus using creators images
without consent, Ariana also attacked my reporting and creators
who spoke to me felt really upset by the way she was behaving.
I told her good luck siding with those exploiting creators by
using their images non-conensually. I have no patience for any
or for anyone like Ariana who intimidate who intimates/att attacks
intimidates maybe intimidates/ attacks those who speak out about
wrongdoing in the creator space. Even now my sources point to
her behavior as reason why they didn't want to speak out publicly.
I do not care for anyone defending bad behavior, period. I will
also note that I've not spoken to Ariana since April. She had
zero to do with my reporting for this story or with the reporting
for my previous story. If she doesn't like me personally, that's
fine. A lot of chorus boosting creators don't like me and I'm
okay with that. One more. No, no, no. Damn.
Taylor is the new Jon of Arc. Okay. No, no. But Taylor,
I just want people to
address the the
actual content of the article. Every single argument I see all
the time is like, well, given the context of the the the tone
of the article, then you have to read it this way. And it's like,
no, I don't. No, I don't. I can read it as like a person who
sees assertions made in a click baiting title and is like, wait,
I don't know if I believe that. I can totally do that. I do that
all the time. In fact, I say for the first like three or four
months of this stream, that was what I did like 50% of the time.
I read a bunch of political stuff on stream and I go, "Whoa,
that'd be that's a crazy claim. Let's see if they back that up."
Yeah, that's super easy to understand. Also, a bunch of people
have an issue with the tone of the article. One, she doesn't
owe you she doesn't owe you writing an article that like is super
kind to you, okay? She doesn't owe that. She might have a a feeling
on the article that comes from some of the people who are, you
know, leaking stuff to her or whatever, and she might write something
with a bit of an attitude.
That might happen. You know where you can help correct the record
and make the article more fair to you?
By responding to requests for comment,
which nobody has disputed she did. Hey, you think this article
is misleading or or misses some context? You know where you were
able to provide that context when she reached out to you directly
and said, "Hey, this is what I'm running. Do you guys have any
comment on this?" That's where you had your chance to go, "Oh,
yeah, we do have comment on it. we actually we actually have
never done that and we don't have any plans to and we need to
just do this for legal reasons. You could fill all that [__]
in. You fill it all in, but you didn't want to. You wanted to
sit back and attack this woman instead of actually making what
you cla instead of making your claims publicly on the record,
right? Or like through Chorus themselves or through some official
representation of Chorus. Instead, it's just a bunch of different
creators attacking Taylor just in a like decentralized way. Wait,
Factorio NFT says, "Starting to think Pixie's lawyers are throwing
Lelo Loren's terrible journalist." Factorio
You can hop on the stream. Okay, hop in the Discord. Let's go.
Hop in the Discord and and show me examples of either of those.
I would love to see it. I would love to see it. Oh, this guy's
going to suck Wick off, too. Now, Factorio NFT,
you believe the article is bad. You believe the article is lying.
feel free to come into the Discord and go, "My vibe on the article
is that she's mean. I don't like her very much and and then,
you know, watch us all take you very seriously with that criticism."
Trust me, I I want to point out to you that Taylor Lorenz is
so correct here that Destiny sat there like a unic on his own
stream and just let Taylor condescend to him the whole time.
Well, don't you think it's like a little weird that you did that?
I understand why you're confused, Destiny. I understand that
you're a little confused. It's okay. I'll explain it to you.
Actual
Unix
the best debater on the internet got totally obliterated by what
most men, most, you know, incelss in the political space considered
the dumbest women online. Till Lorenz, it's like her and Alyssa
Marante were the two dumbest women online. And Destiny got obliterated
by her. How How embarrassing is that? How crazy is that? And
she leaves out crucial context at times to avoid a one-sided
narrative. No, to to force a one-sided narrative would be your
argument. But she didn't leave out crucial context. She reached
out for that context. And Chorus went, "No, no, no. We don't
want to we don't want to say anything else." Okay. If you're
writing an article on like an an accused, okay, they've been
accused by four women of you say, "Hey, do you want to give us
some context?" And the context could be this guy comes in and
goes, "Yeah, actually, um, here's like some context that show
these women were collaborating to accuse me of this."
Oh, that'd be really important. What if they don't? What if they
say no comment? What if they refuse to comment? Well, then you're
running a story about the four women who have accused this person
of Taylor objectively tried to reach out to the people who could
provide that context and they failed to. Every time she called
him confused to his face and he said nothing in return, I kicked
my feet in the air.
Kicked my feet in my chair like a small child. Okay. All right,
man. Amazing stuff.
These comments might be fun. Oh, I bet they could. I bet they
could be fun. unrelated wick clip of him. So, yeah, I've seen
the wick clip on Israel. I
I've seen it.
Vivian Wolf's finest moment. Okay.
Okay, hold on. Do I want to check out this Ozel link? This from
the Is this Taylor Loren's cope? Could we check out a couple
of these? Would these be fun? Would these be funny? Taylor in
Destiny Mega Thread. I wonder
why you do mega threads.
Some clever word play. Oh, hold on. Hold on. I want to do best.
Let's go best. We want the prevailing opinions. Sort by controversial.
Nah.
Taylor's bigger balls than Hassan. Respect. Respect.
Damn.
The burden of proof is on the creators girl. No, the burden of
proof was on her to prove it to the journalistic publication.
The the publication that has not printed a ton of or sorry, the
the publication I should say that when found to be incorrect
on something prints contra uh retractions or corrections, right?
the publication that has a journalistic ethic that they follow.
They she proved it to them and that should be good enough for
people who trust institutions. What is the point of trust and
sorry what is the point of trusting institutions if as soon as
it cuts against you you go oh well now I need you to prove everything
to me. I need you to give me all of your books. I need everything
proven like that. This cuts against everything these people should
stand for. Holy sh I know this this lady. She messages me on
Roblox. Okay. They're claiming the article never mentions the
DNC when the subheading is literally initiative an initiative
aimed at boosting Democrats online offers influencers up to $8,000
a month to push the party line was so dishonest. I I think there
were creators on that side on the procoror side who were arguing
that the DNC and Democratic party are totally different things.
So that's also quite interesting to me. I'm not sure which way
this goes sometimes. When she told him not to interrupt and Destiny
went quiet for a minute, I was I was waiting for the piano so
hard.
Um, dude, it's it's so funny that she looks so good in this.
I I just I'm still shocked. I'm still shocked by this conversation.
That she looks so good in this combo.
Feel like I haven't seen this kind of debater in a while. Media
trained, overly polite, stuck to the talking points like glue.
Oh, she didn't stick to talking point. She just
she literally was just correct. You pound the facts when you're
correct, right?
That feel when your goat was when your goat washed. True. Okay.
Uh, honestly, I didn't see that many really funny things here.
I thought there was uh some other funnier things, but not much
to be honest, cuz they don't consider Loren an actual journalist
backed by Wired for this article and consider her a crazy Twitter
lefty. Yeah, I know. But I hope we all understand that this is
the same argument that all the MAGA people made about every publication
printing stuff about Trump without publishing all of the source
material for that publication. Right?
This is the exact same playbook they used. down to the down to
the tea, man. It's like it's a carbon copy.
It's very sad. Wait, hold on. I missed a Twitch message. Hold
on. I missed it. Never mind. I'll never get back to it now. Never
get back to it now. Unlucky. Oh, what do you think of her? Is
the real question.
What do you think of her is the real question. Jimmy Hennessy.
I don't even know what that
Okay. Three. Well, it's not even three unnamed sources. Dead
Buddha. It's like It's not three unnamed sources. It's they're
alleging to have a ton of evidence. If if you think they're lying,
then you have a defamation lawsuit. You you could sue them, right?
Why aren't they trying to get a retraction from from Wired would
be my question.
Okay, before we get too far down that rabbit hole,
I think before we go before I watch the leftist mafia stuff,
I think I'm going to skip right into this. Okay, >> familiar.
I'm gonna skip right into this content. All right, I'm about
10, 15, 20 minutes into this. I do want to check out a little
bit of this. Okay, just a tiny a tiny an ay weeensy bit. Any
wesy bit, okay, of this panel. Just a little bit of it. I think
about an hour in is where we get uh Fabian starting to kick the
skull in of Hutch.
Uh, proverbally. Proverbally? No, metaphorically kick his skull
in. All right.
Metaphorically. Yeah. Oh, this Kev99 GH guys in the Twitch chat.
Uh, you are a disgusting human being. You need to go. Please
don't come to my things. Please, please go away. Don't come to
any of this. It's like a very gross person. Ben Perma, thank
you. Stick to the cave, brother. Stick to the R cave, okay?
Or whatever Discords you currently inhabit. Either one. Either
one. Stay away from here. Okay. Just make me a mod. Should I
make watching you back a mod on Twitch? Maybe I'll make Watching
You Back a mod on Twitch. Give me a second, guys. Give Watching
You Back mod. Mod Watching You Back. We modded that guy. That
guy's modded. That guy's modded. Let's go. All right,
let's check out a little bit of this. I'm not totally sure how
I'm going to jump around this. I watched a decent amount of it.
I think about an hour in where they start getting a little more
heated. Let's listen to just the beginning. All right. I'm actually
I'm going to skip probably their openings. I think I know what
the opening positions are for all of these people roughly, right?
For these guys, it's going to be, oh, we we think disclosure
is good. For these guys, it's going to be a little more. Okay,
it's going to be like, actually, I think disclosing stuff is
bad because it could put people in danger. Have you thought about
like trans women of color in red states? Have you thought about
that? >> Right. That's why I'm kind of like bringing it
open to you. what I'm pointing out, what I what I would say is
a like a perceived likely um contradiction if you have issue
with like right-wing influencers, rightwing people having transparent
donations that are publicly known and available, right? So, we're
taking out the transparency issue here. Um how is that analogous
to this um to to this concept of like how >> I got to go
back a little bit >> because I think it's very I think
that's a fact. >> Fabian Fabian Liberty can be a little
aggressive sometimes. They may they may have they I think they
may have handled their finances and then connected them with
donors but we don't know if they directly funded >> they're
considered a financial um fin god what was it
1630 go ahead >> I don't think it really matters the point
is money from 1630 or some sort of resources from 1630 are going
to core and I don't think anyone's denying that that's just kind
of out in the open the issue is we don't know what money from
being accused of like attacking and like the point being that
influencing like elections or even larger elections using a disproportionate
amount of money I don't particularly like however being able
to put money into politics to support something that you care
about like hey here's this person who's going to vote for something
that I like here's a million which people sometimes say see it's
lobbying or buying >> million that Elon Musk bumped into
the >> I think there should be caps on the amount of spending
but I'm just saying that like these are different things in the
way that you influence that's just my opinion >> so so
>> I just I don't think you could sit here and say like
oh I'm going to defend this and also get really bad when people
use the same system to beat you right like as I've said already
Elon Musk's Elon Musk and his like lotteryies in Pennsylvania
and Wisconsin were like nuts, right? That was insane. And
man, I I feel like you got to be like on principle. This [__]
all awful, right? But I'm okay with it for like because it's
uh you know, nukes, hydrogen bombs. We need uh we need to have
what do you call it? Um
mutually assured >> You would you would personally say
I've not talked to Fabian before having like 141 million. >> Oh,
wait. There is a Twitter thread. Oh, there is a Twitter thread
about this this uh Hold on. Ah, yes. Can we get Can we get this
right here? Can we check this out? Yes. Hold on. Let me uh
me do this real quick.
This was a funny Twitter thread. Okay, bro.
Dickers covered this. This is before the I think it was before
the the debate. Okay, before the debate.
Wick Wick is going live. Okay, 600 p.m. Eastern. I need I do
need to cover this real quick because it's just very funny. Uh,
this is the first time I'd heard of like Fabian or sorry, this
is the first time I had like any contact with Fabian. I think
he tags me somewhere in in this. Okay.
Um,
so Wick announces the debate from two nights ago. All right.
Or sorry, last night. Last night was the debate. My bad. This
guy asks, "Why dickers?" Wick responds, "Why not?" And this guy
says, "You might as well platform Queen and his other doxing
orbiters. You better play along with his bad faith arguments."
Fabian Liberty comes in and says, "Oh, I don't really follow
all the degenerates and drama people." He literally follows me
on Twitch or sorry, on Twitter, by the way. Look, I mouse over
follows you. So, you do follow both the degenerates and the drama
people. Okay. Liar. Liar.
But he says, "I don't follow them. I only hear in passing that
there are doxing communities and wars. Is this guy someone who
engages in doxing or is that mere a mere accusation?"
This guy comes in and goes, "Meet lumpy Willie." So he he immediately
goes not from
he doesn't go, "Oh, look at Dicker's doing this." He goes, "Meet
Lumpy Willie." Now, I don't believe Lumpy Willie is a doxer at
a base level. Okay, I've never seen anybody suggest to me that
Lumpy Willie is a doxer, but he doesn't even he doesn't even
actually show evidence of him doxing. So, not only does he not
show proof of dickers doing this, he doesn't even show proof
of Lumpy Willie doing this. What? When did Wick have a standard
for doxers on his stream? Uh, he apparently does. But in any
case, this is just funny that you see it's like it's two adjacent
moves. He's like, "Oh, this guy's a doxing community. This guy's
a doxer." And then it's like, but also meet one chatter from
this community who didn't dox anybody who have no proof of doxing.
Cool. Me lumpy Willie Dicker's top Discord user in live stream
chatter. I'm sure Der Dickers disavows this kind of action. Ask
him on stream. Ask him why he attacked Tommy C and called him
a I'm sure he could explain or show evidence of his allegations.
So basically Dickers should be responsible for a chatter's allegations
that they make on Twitter, not even in his stream chat or on
his Discord. This is a tweet from Lumpy Willy that's being referenced.
So nothing that's even happening on one of Dick Dicker's platforms
platforms. And this is if I'm not mistak Yeah, this is spicy
chat. So it's Stylo posting a Lumpy Willy tweet and then he shows
the Lumpy Willy tweet. Do you see how bad these guys are at making
their arguments? This Denal person is Tommy C's top agent. Uh,
incredible stuff. Incredible stuff. So, someone active in his
chat is threatening doxing crazy. I am genuinely trying to understand
this. It just seems that like a tenuous It just seems a tenuous
connection. Is there any evidence Lumpy Willie actually doxes
people as opposed to just being a crazy person or that they do
so under the direction of of the this dicker TV person? Direction
or aid of this dicker TV person? Like my chat has groers and
psychos in it. They break to I give him a chat timeout and I
move on. Lol. Oh, Fabian is understanding just being an adult.
Cool. Ask Dickers and you will see. There's plenty of evidence
out there. Even Desessie has a perfect understanding of who these
people are and who they bring along with them. Oh, is this a
Is this a Tommy? This is a Tommy C fellow. Even Destiny knows.
Queen, Aiden, Dickers, Perry, and JC are all collaborating together
and share the same deranged fan base. There is a reason why no
one collaborates with
Do we share the same fan base? I think my fans are fans of Queenman,
vice versa. Like we we have people who overlap for sure, but
like I think there's a decent amount of overlap. I think he's
streaming right now. He probably streams to like roughly the
same amount of viewers that I have or more, right? I think there
is overlap there, but it's like not crazy overlap. It's not like
one. We stream I think half of our streams occur over in an overlapping
nature. Wouldn't that be a huge mistake if we just shared the
same audience? Anyway, okay. Can you send me a video or article
or collection of this evidence? I promise I have no connections
to any drama farmers, etc. I just followed JTO the other day
after I saw a reaction pop up to me taking down Connor. I only
overlap on these occasional debate panels. Okay, I understand.
My views are very biased. I would advise you to do your own research
and come to your own conclusion. Yeah, do your own research.
I don't want to talk to you about any of this. Do your own research,
bud. You said you were familiar with Queenman and his reputation,
so it's a good start. As I said, they're all Destiny's anti-fans.
hardcore anti-fans. They all share the same community. They officially
disavow doxing and harassment. However, it's always their community
that does it.
All anyone's asking for is is proof of this. That's all we want.
We just want proof of any of this. Just any. They just keep making
this up. It's best to ask other creators who interacted with
Queenman. I think Hutch has some experience with it. Dickers
is Queman's loyal soldier.
Okay. I think Dickers and I are closer than Queen and Dickers.
Come on. Come on, man. So, how how does Fabian respond if you
have a Oh, right. Sorry. Sorry. So, he asks, "Oh, if you have
a video or something digestible, I have no issue looking at it,
but I don't deal with these people except in passing. My channel
is debates, sure, but mostly reactions based on anarchist and
objectivist philosophy. I'm not interested in a do your own research
in a do your own research response. It screams antivax mom who
can't provide any evidence for her claims. And to be honest,
I just don't care about this space, the entire space of clickbait
drama tubers who form engagement off of shock content. You have
a strong opinion and I'm engaging with you. Is there not a single
YouTube video documenting these claims in the entire drama-filled
YouTube space? If so, I highly doubt they're anything but hearsay.
Oh, wow. Wow.
True. It's all heresy. I'm a crazy person. Nice try with the
antivaxers. Bravo. I have no skin in the game. I'm not debating
you, bro. It's like actually 100% an antivax bomb, dude. Fabian.
Fabian didn't cave only one skull in yesterday. He caved multiple
skulls in yesterday. Holy sh you Fabian Liberty. It's Paragon.
Wait, how do you know it's Paragon? No way. Wait, what is that
based on? Is that based on any actual information? This is star-based.
This is Paragon. Starbased? No way. Oh, no skin in the game.
I have no skin in the game. Oh,
I get it. I get it. I get it. I was a little slow there. Didn't
get it at first. Now I do. I'm not asking you to debate, lol.
Trust me, this is me being this is me being nice. You're claiming
someone is a part of a doxing network and I'm a content creator
going on a panel with them in a few hours. One with children
in radical politics. I am rightly concerned and simply ask you
for a video or article or something that documents this. But
when I ask, you respond with do your own research. You know what
how this is or that is? I'm not going to quit a panel on rumors.
This is my job. But if you have an if you have actual evidence
you're going to just sit and watch people put their families
at risk of doxing such swatting. This is a serious accusation
you have levied against Stickers TV and one that puts me and
everyone else on the panel in an uncomfortable position. All
I am asking for is proof of your
Dickers just confirmed that Lumpy Willie is there to wind him
up. Below are two examples of who Willie really is. More hardcore
stuff was wiped from their discords as soon as word got out.
On top of that from Aiden's who is Dickertop guy.
Wait, now Aiden's Aiden is uh Dicker's from Aiden's. Who is Dicker's
top guy? Bro, can't these people can't these people copy us without
skinwalking us? Like Like why are you saying top guy? We say
top guy. That's our lingo.
How you going to copy us and then go like we hate you? You can't
copy all my lingo and then say you hate me. You [__]
you. This is top guy. Did Did Aiden survive Malta? Only because
only because he didn't drink the beer Perry handed him. Okay.
Perry meant to have him like uh passed out in that hotel room.
All right. When the fire was going on,
Dickers, well-known Dickers orbiter, Aiden Underground. All right.
Aiden is a loyal loyal devote
of Dickers. Okay. Incredible stuff. Perry built like a Roblox
character. Dude, I need to I should keep some of the Perry stuff
like on hand. Bro, some of the Perry gifts were soing funny.
Hold on. I think I think Porter Beller sent me like a hundred.
So, I'm scrolling my Porter Beller DMs looking for my parry gifts.
Where are my parry gifts at? Where are my Perry gifts at? There
we go. There we go. Incredible stuff, guys. Oh, it wasn't just
it wasn't just Porter Beller, but I also Yeah, one of them broke,
so had a bunch of them. They were awesome.
Perry won. Perry won. Perry won. Perry won.
I'll say it a million times until you all understand that Perry
won. Where were we here? So, confirmed lumpy Willy's in there.
More hardcore stuff was wiped from the Discord. Aiden's a dicker's
lieutenant. Funny little dono regarding the user Aiden showed
on stream. They all have a funny sense of humor. I don't have
a docket with the evidence. I just found this in the last 10
minutes. Spare me your do your own research. BS. It's your job
to do a background check on your panelists. I wish Dicker didn't
block me as soon as he wanted me to respond.
Wait.
Orders understood, boss. will have his name on your desk by Friday.
Oh, no way. They're just going to reuse this one? Yes. Understood,
sir. Understood. Did Now, here's the real question, guys.
Did Aiden laugh at this? If Aiden laughed at this, that's up.
Okay. Could you imagine if Aiden laughed at this and basically
confirmed that he wanted it to happen immediately? That would
be that would be nuts. Okay. to get away from me. These days
I think are so strange.
Wow. Wow. Incredible. 620 concurrent. Um I don't know when this
was. Maybe.
What? What was this stream? I've never seen him with 620, but
he gets like two 200 250 sometimes. I've seen that pretty uh
pretty consistently like 200 250 at his high moments. Okay. Anyway,
see let's see. Let's see.
Reggeeman, who is Dicker's top guy?
Dickers's top guy. Everybody's everyone's top guy. What? Everyone's
a top guy. Sure, Dickers can gaslight about Lumpy Willie and
others. The facts and their reputation is wellnown. The whole
community and their viewers are just toxic.
What is happening? See, I would almost believe that this is star-based,
but it's like clearly
it's it's clearly somebody just using like uh ah nothing. Sir,
have you know do you know that these are doxing communities?
Do you know sir?
Okay. All right. Back to the debate. >> 196
all these other groups. >> Wait, why is Fabian muted? >> So,
there's two two things here. One, uh, yeah, I I would support
their mission, which is we want to kind of like make ourselves
not be a thing anymore. Um, although they are using the thing
they're fighting against to do that, so it's like questionable.
But what you're really looking into is they are a 5013C I think
not a four right cuz there's technic >> my sound is back
my sound is back I >> anymore although they are using the
thing they're fighting against to do that so it's questionable
but what you're really looking into is they are a 5013C I think
not for right cuz they're technically non-political versus hey
you know this whole thing was an incubator program to help out
people get better at making content not I'm putting money directly
into Donald Trump's campaign to help him win the election. I
think those are very different things. I I think we can skip
a lot of this part of the conversation because I I think your
framing is a bit silly because like you can be against big like
dark money influences in politics and at the same time recognize
that it's tactically stupid to unilaterally disarm. So like there's
nothing there's nothing incompatible about Democrats saying ideally
we wouldn't have this type of money influencing politics and
at the same time recognizing that if Charlie Kirk didn't take
in $80 million for TP USA like us just >> why is the one
guy wearing a dunce cap? I don't know. Soy pill just roll like
that. Okay. standing on virtue or principle and cutting ourselves
off from that kind of funding. There's just no tactical way that
you could really defend that. So, >> wait, wait, wait,
wait. You can kind of be anti dark money and also receive dark
money. I think that's possible. I think you can do I think I
do think this argument is reasonable. This unilater non this
this nonunilateral disarmament. Okay, I think that's reasonable.
It's a reasonable argument, but you got to start there. Okay,
you got to start there. You can't like virtue signal and tell
other people they're lying or or wrong or misinformed when they
call you up for getting dark money. You go, "Yeah, I am getting
dark money cuz those Republicans are getting dark money." Don't
go, "Oh, your whole article is debunked. You're lying."
No, shut up. Just say that's what you're doing. Just say that's
what you're doing and say, "Yeah, we should disclose that." There's
nothing wrong with disclosing it, but yeah, we're going to take
that money. We're going to eat that money up. Okay?
Eat that money up. Yum, yum, yum, yum. Yummy in my tummy. This
panel was awesome. Oh, I hope so. I've watched I've listened
to a decent amount of it, but in sections, so I kind of I kind
of have it disjoint in my head. I'm gonna get some caffeine real
quick. I'm going to hit play. I'm listening. Might use a bathroom
really quick as well.
But here we go. Here we go. H about it that I do >> principles
or moral any moral beliefs that you stand by. >> No. But
I'll kill someone. >> The weapon of the enemy is bad. Therefore,
I will pick up the weapon. There's no like there's no self-defense
claim here, right? If you're against the very weapon. >> Also,
does anybody know we might we might have the first bad empanada
video ever on stream, but it would only be bad empanada did a
food shops video. And let me tell you, I'm intrigued if there's
no doxing information in it. If there's doxing stuff in it, I'm
not going to watch the video at all cuz I don't want to support
him when he does that kind of [__] okay? I don't
want to have him on my stream. I would watch the video if it's
a video without any of that kind of information in it. But but
it would have to be without any of that doxing information. If
if doxing is in it, I'm not interested. So I'd check it out.
Anyway, I I just figured I'd ask if anyone knows >> weapon
itself. Then you can't say I'm against the weapon, but I choose
to pick up the weapon. >> What's the point of having a
principle if it's an existential threat to your entire party?
>> One time, let's not really a principle >> No,
it is. >> Let's Let's give it to Hutch. Let's give it a
D real quick. Go ahead. >> Let's just like is is Bad Ampanada.
Okay, hold on. And this free pie guy says, "Bad Ambana gets very
annoyed if you react to his content on stream, especially if
he thinks you are a Destiny ally."
Uh, that's okay.
I'm not I'm not concerned about that. Listen, I'm already It's
already like uh like we've said, GTA 5 stars out here already.
Okay. What's one more What's one more guy gunning for my head?
Okay, it's really nothing. We're going to go ahead. divides a
hypothetical where you know you have this like small hunter gatherer
group of you know 50 people or whatever and there's you know
guns exist in this world but this group they don't think that
guns should like be a part of their society but then another
you know group comes and starts attacking them with guns would
it be unprincipled for the 50 first people to like >> well
that's why that's why I use the analogy of saying it's not about
the concept of self-defense it's about the concept of the guns
themselves right so if you're against the guns and you say I
am a pacifist I am a pacifist I'm a pacifist I'm a pacifist and
then you get attacked and you go actually I'm not really a pacifist
let me grab the guns right like Would you eat a Would you eat
a human being? >> Would I eat a human being? >> Yeah.
Would you eat a human being? >> Circumstances. Yeah, sure.
>> Oh. Oh, wait. So, it's not a principle that you wouldn't
eat a human being. >> I never said that I had a principle
that I wouldn't eat a human being. >> You wouldn't eat
a human being. >> Well, isn't it everybody else and they're
dead? Do you think? Yeah. >> Yeah. So, maybe there are
like extenduating circumstances to perhaps go against what would
normally be your principles because otherwise you would die or
something would be so threatened that it wouldn't matter that
you held your principal. Do you realize that's like a very easy
concept to understand? I think this so when I'm pointing out
what I believe is is is a likely >> Sorry, I'm not back
yet. But what what the [__]
what the [__]
is Soy Pill's
problem? What is what is soy pill's major malfunction with that?
Uh would you do would you eat a human? Yeah, probably. Uh so
you're saying you don't have a principle against eating a human?
Uh yeah, that's literally what I just said. Yes. Yes, that is
literally what I just said.
What are we doing here? Uh,
Dude, that's
No, but like but like the answer was obvious from his first like
that's a question you could ask, but you're like do do you think
cannibalism is ethically wrong was the first question you have
to have to ask, right? And then if he says no, like obviously
there are cases under which I'd engage in cannibalism
like then then you then you go somewhere, right? Or sorry, then
you stop. But that's what happened. As soon as he says yeah to
you, human, it's over. You stop with that line of questioning.
He like he like started he kept going down the uh the logic tree,
his like his like railroad. He was trying to railroad this guy
and he didn't even listen to the first answer. >> Do you
think? Yeah. >> Yeah. So maybe there So it's not a principle
that you wouldn't eat a human
>> I never said that I had a principle that I wouldn't
eat a human being. >> So you would eat a human being. >> Well,
isn't it implied to everybody else and they're dead? >> Do
you think Yeah. So maybe there are like extenduating circumstances
to >> Dude. Dude,
that's that's rough. Okay, this guy must be nervous or something.
I don't even know.
This incredible kick getting all the love and attention. This
is I honestly forgot Twitch chat was there. You guys just don't
move very fast. If you guys move faster, maybe I would look What
was the last thing Centauri said? Centauri said, "Doxing rules
is kind of strict on Twitch. It's about sharing any personal
information about a person whether they are from public sources
or not. Uh I don't think that is necessarily the case, Centauri.
But we'll we'll get into it. We'll see exactly what the rules
are and we can go back over it. But I I still have to use the
bathroom. I didn't even use the bathroom. I had to come back
cuz Soy Bill's question was so >> Perhaps go against what
would normally be your principles because otherwise you would
die or something would be so threatened that it wouldn't matter
that you held your principal. Do you realize that's like a very
easy concept to understand? this. So, when I'm pointing out what
I believe is is is a likely because I don't like I'm not intimately
familiar with everyone on this panel's content, right? That's
why I'm kind of like bringing it open to you. When I'm pointing
out what I what I would say is a like a perceived likely um contradiction
if you have issue with like right-wing influencers or right-wing
people having transparent donations that are publicly known and
available, right? So, we're taking out the transparency issue
here. Um, how is that analogous to this um to to this concept
of like how how is that analogous to like cannibalism or >> So
the idea was cannibism which you can say analogous and that's
fine. No, no, no. That's fine. I'm just showing you that sometimes
principles need to be violated for certain extenduating circumstances.
And in this case, if I could show you, now this isn't necessarily
true. I'm not asking you to believe this, but if dark money would
be ended by electing Democrats, would you not use dark money
to do that? Would that be unprincipled? >> I mean, if your
number one thing is, I won't use dark money. Dark money. Well,
that's no one's number one thing is I won't use dark money in
the Democratic
>> That that's just uh that that there's there's so much
you could justify. That's quite literally the argument Trump
used. Okay. Don't you guys hate don't you guys hate them trying
to change your kids? Well, elect me and I'll get rid of that.
It's like, okay, I actually hold on. That's not quite Trump's
argument. Okay, we didn't know this was Trump's argument, but
Trump is actually following this exact thing. Vote for me. Okay,
I'll only do a little with Jeffrey Epsteine and I can expose
the rest of them, guys. So vote for me. I'm using to eliminate.
Okay. That's the Trump message. >> We're doing Yeah, but
that's that's fine. We're doing a univaried analysis based on
principle. >> I do want to give it to Prime. >> So
you're you're attacking me for
>> Like that's so stupid. >> I don't know if they're
going to be if like if you're a single issue voter and your single
issue voting is I'm against dark money.
>> Okay, stop there because that's the hypothetical that
no one is participating in. >> Okay. This is Is this not
the bridge that connects?
Everybody's like, "Oh, we we need to tell Donald Trump to prosecute
Destiny." You really think Donald Trump's going to, you know,
one white hat PDF, one white hat to another? You really think
he's going to prosecute Destiny? They both know the game. Okay.
They're trying to clean the world up one child exploited at a
time. All right. >> You're no like I think at this point
>> who is single issue dark money? That's the analogy you're
giving me is about whether or not
this play.
Let's see if we can get something else going on here, please.
>> No, that's not why I'm interrupting.
>> All right. Well, um uh
I'm familiar with Scott and I know uh how he rolls um and how
he said multiple times that he wouldn't like steal a dollar to
save the world or something like that. Um >> Yeah. Yeah.
Um so, and he's been I mean he's he he hasn't bent from this
rule. To be clear, we haven't had an apocalypse that required
him to pick up a dollar. But still, that's enough. >> Still
still though, you still wouldn't do it.
>> I would not steal a penny to save the world. Correct.
>> But you would but but you would eat a person to live.
>> Yeah. A dead person's a dead person. I'm not a Christian.
>> Okay. I don't I want to get back to chorus. I want to
get back to
>> I don't I'm not here to debate whether we should eat
people. I'm here to debate Chorus. We're going to stick on Chorus
at least for the next
>> You You'd really Hold on. You'd really eat somebody
to stay alive, but you wouldn't take dark money. Yeah, like self-preservation.
Yeah, that's like uh pretty high on my values. Okay. Pretty high
on the things I prioritize. Staying alive. Yes. Do you need to
take dark money to stay alive? No, you don't. Shut up. 30 minutes.
If we just we can move on from apologize. I refuse to argue principles
as a person cuz it's ridiculous to say, "Oh, you'd use dark money
to end dark money, you hypocrites." Like, would you steal a penny
to save 8 billion people? No. Okay. able to shut the >> This
is such a stupid argument. >> What evidence is there that
the Democrats would end dark money? Does this does this not realize
that you just had a damn president? Isn't Citizens United a like
a Supreme Court case? How do you end dark money with like a Supreme
Court president is the thing that enabled it? Am I missing something?
I thought this was like Supreme Court presidents that were based
off of the
Does Can you even elect somebody? Can you even elect your way
out of that? You need like a constitutional amendment, right?
Or some Yeah, you need like a constitutional amendment. There's
no >> Okay. Some of us is morally consistent. >> Guys,
just let us use dark money until we have a supermajority that
we can pass constitutional amendments with with ease. Okay. Obviously,
come on, man. >> I don't care. Please. >> Okay. And
the difference here is a um non-aggression principle, but you
can talk about that later. Um anyway, um so
Scott is familiar with my content. Um and uh I don't think maybe
that shot was like at me, but still I want to address uh would
the pill lad not talk to you on this? He might. He might. I honestly
I just don't see
I feel like when I watch this, I feel like having direct conversations
with these people is going to be yikesy. Cuz when I listen to
them speak, they're just shilling. And trust me, I've spent a
lot of time looking at this at this point, okay? Like I don't
want to tell I don't want to accuse these people of what I have
to accuse them of to like do the content where I converse with
them. Okay? Seems like we only had Really and no one else comes
on, it seems. Uh I don't invite other I haven't invited anybody
on over this. Well, hold on. I invited um I I could talk to Litterbox.
Litterbox said he would do a panel with me. Um, but I think he
double booked on Wednesday and then I wasn't here yesterday.
So, I could probably message Lonerbox and ask if he wanted to
talk. Really has come on already. We talked about it. I'm just
saying a lot of this
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Matt Slice, I got it as well. Um, Dude, it's
I this soy pill guy specifically. Okay.
This soy pill guy, I want to ask him a question I would love
to ask is, are you trying to prove to everybody through performance
art that IRI is? Cuz if you guys missed Live and Learn, okay,
IRI basically was arguing that like actually political influencers
are just really noble. They're really principled and money wouldn't
change their politics at all. And then Soy Pill, as if to blatantly
disprove that, suddenly just started arguing super hard about
how like, yeah, no, no, actually, it's really dangerous to disclose
where your money comes from, and you should do you shouldn't
have to do that at all. Also, Chorus, will you pay me? Chorus,
will you pay me? Chorus, will you pay me? This is very funny.
the question you put forward um like so I have been critical
of billionaires putting money into politics the entire time um
and uh I am also critical of this formulation right so I I have
two objections one um on the lack of disclosure um the seeming
lack of disclosure and two uh the fact that it's being funded
by these unknown dark money billionaire donors um doesn't really
sit well with me um and my uh problem specifically and other
people might have different opinions on this um one I don't think
billion exist I think the problem with them putting money into
politics is not necessarily just them putting money into politics
act itself, but the fact they can put so much money into politics
that they have so much >> Wait, which guy are you talking
about? This guy, the soy pill guy. >> Leverage, right?
Um to speak in a in a way that the average individual can't.
So, it'd be fine. >> We don't know who they are. So, how
do we know they're billionaires? Okay, they could owe $999 million.
Okay, you don't know that they're billionaires cuz we don't know
who the they are. >> Some people are billionaires who do
disclose even though they're not legally have to. So, George
Soros, Amid are like there are some of these billionaires. And
Elon Musk is just one. So, he's just saying the principle is
I don't like the billionaires have this much influence. >> Yeah,
you don't have to explain my joke to the audience. It's okay.
>> You're libertarian. I can't tell when you're joking,
dude. Sometimes you're saying something very serious. >> So
So yeah. Um I I I uh I think that you know us, you know, as a
panel, let's say we wanted to abandon the seven of us on this
on this uh stream. Um and decided to put out a political message,
right? We put together a maker fund to do so. >> I'm going
to skip through parts where I think it like slows down. Okay,
I can retry if I have to do that. That's fine. Um so I think
it's fine to do that on this level, but that's you know relatively
even ground and a amount of money that most people can actually
match. we can't match um the leverage power of billionaires,
right? They're on a completely literally exponentially logarithmically
different level than we are. And that's my issue. >> Okay.
Can I address that though? Because yes, I agree with what you're
saying. I really don't like the billionaire in influence. But
this specific project was saying, "Hey, creators that don't have
the influence of like a Charlie Kirk or these people who just
have millions and millions and millions of dollars of donation,
we want to give some of that billionaire money to you so that
you do have a larger voice and can spread the message that says
we want these billionaires out of politics, which I fully agree
with even though in principle I have the same princip.
Is it any part of Chorus's platform that they are against money
and politics? Cuz I think this is 1630 platform is against money
and politics. >> I you can look this up if you read the
wire article. I don't know if you read the article we're talking
about. >> [__] hilarious. >> No, I did.
It doesn't say anything about money and politics. >> Click
on the links when it says 1630 fund. I can send it to you in
trap.
>> Oh,
hold on. Click on the links when it says 1630 fund. Well, if
you read the article, you know 1630 fund didn't fund uh or or
does, you know, promote getting money out of politics. And Dick's
like, "Oh, I didn't see that in the article. I don't think that's
in the article." He goes, "Well, if you click the link to the
1630 funds platform, like what?" >> So, it's not in the
article, but it's >> it's it's referenced directly in the
article. Yeah, you can. So, that's in one extra click. I'm sorry.
>> Okay. I'm just like
million dollar.
>> Does like
that just means Soy pill is wrong. You're just wrong when you
say that. It's it's in the article.
Okay.
Unless it's Maybe it's not Maybe it is in the article. I don't
I don't actually remember whether or not that's one of the things
I remember they say that I think Taylor says something like I
don't necessarily even hate the things that 1630 advocates for
and it's like you know reproductive rights and some other things
right >> fund over the last 10 years saying they want money
out of politics. >> It's not ironic at all. It's not ironic
to people that don't take this absolutist view of principles.
Like I think you're the only one on the panel that has this view.
>> Yeah. Well, yeah. I'm also the only one on the panel
that's like even like like anywhere past center of right. Right.
So obviously like down to logical moral positions aren't really
a thing on the left. um maybe see in some tanky spaces, right?
But like for the for the most part, you're going to be utilitarians
or consequentialists of some variety, right? So so obviously
as the only person not leftwing here, yeah, of course I'm the
only person on the panel that believes in strict moral principles
as opposed to negotiating with our principles to use evil to
defeat a big bigger evil. >> The vast majority of the right
is probably going to be in favor of this kind of dark money,
too, right? I mean, like we see a lot of right-wing initiatives
using the same exact business model. That's not that like a >> Yeah.
No, I I'm no I'm no fan of
>> I agree. I don't I don't think the panel
>> uh gave Lon Box a lot of respect for years, but I think
he's really losing his to be honest. Dude, ban me out of the
blue. Newish account. I get it. For simply correcting Hutch's
misinformation about Destiny.
Well, hold on. Did he did he ban you or did like his mods ban
you? Did he call you out specifically? I actually don't I would
want to know. But I do think I think some people are just wrong
on this and in a way that like feels offputting to me. I don't
know how to describe it.
I I don't know. I have to look more into I I need to see the
individual's takes to feel comfortable, but I've
there's there's something weird going on here. >> Get bogged
down by like a meta ethics, you know, debate. I think we should
probably just like stick on the uh the article and do we can
I just ask this here? Maybe we'll get this back on >> a
moral question about this money and >> But it's also a
question about whether or not the article was a fair article.
Do we think, let me start with this question. Do we think that
the article as written was an accurate and fair assessment of
what is going on at Chorus? Why?
So it is not on the author to so it's on the author to to do
a certain amount of research right now. The the claim is well
while these contract provisions are correct and these contract
provisions could seem scary in practice we do something different
with them and we could explain that to you. Right? That's that's
the answer they had. Okay. So why when when Taylor Loren reaches
out for comment do you not say anything? You're holding that
context there that would make the article say and be say the
things you want it to say and be somewhat fair and you choose
to withhold that context from her. You do not comment and you
go, "Oh, I can't believe how unfair you are."
It's almost like you wanted to do that, right? LBox was seriously
arguing that Dpack mispronouncing Apac was a joke. Uh
uh maybe excuse me I give that like a 10% chance only because
Dpack does really really off timing jokes like that or sorry
not like like he does jokes like that saying something like seriously
I've seen that before from him. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I've seen that
kind of joke from him but um I don't know man.
I don't know. I possibly
I know he mispronounces Tik Tok but I I didn't get the semblance
like you can't
that's one of those things where if you're going to make jokes
but also imply that you are if it's a joke that totally confirms
or totally like supports you in the thing you're saying. It's
like
uh how how I don't know what a good analogy is but he's basically
saying no no no I'm not like an Israel shill. I don't even know
what Apex stands for. Right. It's like, but you you're you are
trying to argue you're not an Israel shill. You're not joking
about not being an Israel shill. So doing the joke that like
supports that is a little weird to me because you're being serious
about that you don't support it, right? Like that that's what's
weird to me. >> Why or why not? >> I I don't think
you can say that. like with I mean there there could be particular
things in the contract that were referenced that are you know
technically true but what we discovered in the especially in
like the 48 hours after the article was dropped and we heard
you know >> also what
why if if Taylor Loren doesn't believe she's wrong and she believes
that you're using these contracts to sort of get this dark money
out there without being called out for it if she believes that
what responsibility does she have to be fair to you on it that
like you you have these contracts these contracts
do shape some things that happen with these influencers, right?
Like if if these influencers have to ask your permission to be
able to disclose, there's going to be a bunch of influencers
who just go, they don't want us disclosing. I'm not going to
disclose, right? Objectively, that is true. So, obviously, Taylor
Loren might still write this article. I don't know that she's
I don't know that she has a responsibility to not write the article
with like the the tone she wants for it, right? Every time I
see I've seen Oh, sorry. This is about Deepac. Wasn't he just
playing into the Israel show thing a bit in that moment? As a
bit in that moment. Oh, I don't think so. I don't think he was,
but maybe maybe if I go back to it. I think he is kind of an
Israel shill to be honest with you. Like, as in he he doesn't
really criticize them at all. Um, yeah.
And kind of runs some soft cover. I I think I think based on
some stuff I've seen, but hey, it's a I've seen like a curated
collection of clips. If you showed me like him calling out a
lot of the wrongdoings of Israel in Gaza,
I I'd be convinced he's more like centrist on it for sure. responses
from people in the program. It's just in practice, the way that
that program was working really did not look anything like what
was described in that article, particularly the subheading that
I think was the most egregious sort of mischaracterization because
she said that these creators were secretly paid to push the party
line and that just appears to be just on its face just not what
was happening. >> Well, also I'd like to say to say like
to agree to restrictions on their content absolutely plays into
the idea that they can't talk about Gaza either. Like I'm almost
willing to bet that that's where a lot of those people got that
impression. I think that's Taylor herself, she was tweeting,
you know, she she like spoke with Destiny yesterday and she denies
I mean she even clified that nothing in her reporting or nothing
in her investigation gave her any kind of indication that people
were prevented from talking about Gaza. But you know
>> not prevented but she she did suggest that like oh they
don't talk about Gaza.
Not that they were told they can't but that they don't. >> A
few days before she was tweeting out I can confirm that you know
of the list that we saw most of them are very centristy. So she
was definitely like throwing red meat to like the lefty kind
of media ecosystem. And boy, why is that inaccurate? You haven't
got any evidence to the claim that that's inaccurate. Why is
that inaccurate? >> Because people are making videos criticizing
Israel and criticizing the Democratic party. >> I think
it's a matter of framing and not so much a matter of like particular
facts that were misrepresented. It's more so like the framing
of it or the the lack of detail that's given in >> Okay.
Maybe maybe so like my read right and maybe maybe you guys can
then so I'm not trying to get you to prove a negative, right?
Like my read of it is when you are supporting people by giving
them some level of funds, right? If we want to talk specifically
about the incubator program where they're getting like somewhere
between $250 and 8K, right? Um a month. Like if if you're giving
people money um and you're giving them presumed opportunities
and you're saying we're going to give you access, we're going
to give you funds so that you can have a bigger platform and
do more things. We're going to connect you with other people
and also we want you to sign this contract that says you're not
really supposed to talk about it and also you're supposed to,
you know, coordinate messaging twice a month or at least get
trained in like the DM the Democrats messaging, right? Twice
a month. uh once a week get trained in democratic uh policy positions
or you know policy positions that jive with 1630
and five times a week once a day okay you have a daily messaging
check-in I dude I think that doesn't get talked about enough
and I I understand that we don't know what those look like but
come on man why is it called daily messaging check-in why would
why did Brian Tyler Cohen explicitly say he wants the messaging
on point for the Dems why was that an explicit goal of this group
of course media group when they started. >> No, no, no.
That's not what that's not what it was.
>> That's not what her article said. She she even clarified
that the DNC had nothing to do with this. So, >> yeah.
So, the checkins that you're referencing I'm not saying literally
the DNC. I'm talking about the program that you're referencing
program that is record the program that is that is that is that
is supporting these people, right? That is obviously has a message
of their own. Even if it's not direct party line perfect messaging
that the BNC wrote for them word for word, right? These are this
is a a program that is funded by neoliberals, you know, centrist
left, you know, um uh billionaires because they're not leftist
billionaires. They don't [__] exist, right? And so,
right, so you have that
>> it's a contradiction.
Liberals. Sure. Stakeholder capital. >> Yeah. It is in
the name. Okay. It is in the name, but you when you guys are
like, it's in the name. They're a chorus. What is a chorus? It's
a group of people singing to the same harmony. They're harmonizing
for the Democrats. It's I
It's accurate, but it also is like it's accurate as a trap for
you. Okay. It's accurate as a trap for you. Don't play into it.
capitalism, corporist, socialist, neoliberal, whatever [__]
term you want to use, right? But these are center-left portion
of the party. Maybe they have some progressive values on like
healthcare or some [__] We're talking about like
leftist leftist. If if you have all of those things and you know
that, okay, this is the messaging that my program that's paying
me and giving me opportunities that I'm not supposed to talk
about is is putting out, how is that not having a chilling effect
on speech? How is that not what they're paying for? We have to
control the >> because there's no indication that this
was happening. Like we wait there is there is wait I do have
even though I'm on your side the chilling effect thing I think
is a valid argument because it is true that some of them do give
testimonies of I'm worried that maybe I'm not supposed to talk
about certain things. Now whether or not those were valid concerns
they could have worked out with chorus. Clearly they were people
talking about chorus. I think like people are confusing hey don't
disclose other members because that might be private information.
Hey don't disclose like when we have events before the publicly
announced as like weren't allowed to talk about chorus. These
are very different things but there could be an effect of hey
what if I want to suddenly became MAGA today when I get kicked
out. That could be a concern, but that's also
be clear. I wanted to give some validity to it, but to push back,
that's everything. That's audience capture. That's like, hey,
what makes money with the algorithm? There's always a showing
effect somewhere. Now, I don't this money wasn't coming as a
political amount of money. This was an incubator program for
getting people off the ground and expanding their reach. It wasn't
here's your talking points. The daily check-ins were, hey, we
taught you how to do shorts. Let's see if your shorts are doing
well. Hey, let's see how your thumbnails are doing. Like, these
people weren't being paid to just >> Wait, wait, wait,
wait, what? >> As a political amount of money. This was
an incubator program for getting people off the ground and expanding
their reach. It wasn't, here's your talking points. The daily
check-ins were, hey, we taught you how to do shorts. Let's see
if your shorts are doing well. Hey, >> what? I don't Is
that what she said? I don't think that's what Ally said about
the daily messaging check-ins. I The only person I've seen talk
about the uh the daily messaging check-ins was the Ali 202 person.
>> Hello, I am a leftist. >> Hold on. She pulls up
her schedule here,
>> Yeah. Every single day. They are outperforming us in
volume incredibly because they just make sure accomplish to count.
this country is recently it's been a lot of people who work in
like immigration explaining I and we all get a chance to ask
like questions if we want to know how a specific update meeting
we meet for 15 minutes I wake up and I'm immediately just told
what the news of the day is um and we all get a chance to ask
like questions if we want to know how a specific lawsuit is developing
or what is Trump expected to do next with the national guard
right we're just making sure we're all the most informed these
are very >> so it has it has nothing to do at all with
equipment or meta meta you know like uh sorry data analysis on
your channel.
There's He's literally just lying. He's just making that up.
He just made it up. Huh? Me when I lie. Me when I lie. Soy pill
just doing a little lie over here, guys. Oops. Someone get someone
get me that lavoon clip stat. Okay. Sometimes Soy Pill just opens
his mouth and a lie just
falls out. It just falls out. >> Okay. Let's see how your
thumbnails are doing. Like these people were being paid to just
do whatever they were doing already. It was trying to expand
them into having more of a voice. To be clear, I was
>> Hutch and then Dickers. Hutch and then Dickers. That's
where we're not addressing the argument, but okay. >> To
be clear, I was gonna get >> I Man, I should have gone
on some panels for this. Maybe. Maybe I should have gone on a
panel or something cuz I just feel like every time I listen to
these people talk, I I it's like in my head like these I I just
I see where everybody's lying. It's like, stop stop lying, dude.
Teone was right. Hold on. Tone was so right. For real. Okay.
Tecton was so real when he said, "The more you learn, the more
you inform yourself in this world, you realize things are bad,
man. There's just there there's there's so little good people
in this world, right? Can we w techone in the chat?" WTONE, you're
so real for >> They're on my own. Have more faith in your
pod, brother. >> I'm sorry. >> It's fair to have
that kind of thought, right? Because as soon as you hear that
some creator is being paid by some source that is involved in
politics, that's of course going to be the first question that
pops into your mind. However, what became abundantly clear again
in the couple days or subsequent week after this reporting is
that this was not happening in any kind of material sense like
there was no there's no actual evidence of this happening. There
are 90 people in the program. Don't you think that at least one
of them would have gone on background with Taylor to tell her
like yeah I wanted to talk about this thing and then you know
they got this is by the way the the weird total alignment of
talking points on on how to like question the article also just
seems bizarre to me. I don't know if that's people getting formed
the same way and asking the same question, but this insistence
that you have to be prevented from saying something, right? That
you have to be that you have to be explicitly told uh that a
topic is off limits or a position is off limits for there to
be restrictions on your content. That is not true, right? And
the idea that they they're basically saying, "Oh, well, you can't
talk about Israel, Gaza," or something, the idea that that's
that that's a requirement for them to make the claims they did,
is preposterous. And it's weird to me that everybody just falls
into line on that. Like you can't push a narrative without restricting
people. You can't push a narrative by with only positive feedback.
You need negative feedback to push a narrative. That's nuts.
>> You know, they push back and they don't. >> That's
not my argument. You're saying this isn't happening, but you're
not addressing the argument that I made. What you're doing is
you're bringing in outside factors of what like of what you saw
on Twitter so that you can defeat that straw man. That has nothing
to do with the argument that I'm making. The argument that I'm
making is that when you are picked and you are chosen to be a
part of a program that is people who align they're going to be
picked with people who align with their policy goals. Of course
I never made that claim that like they're forcing this type of
speech on people. >> But there's a difference between that
and quote unquote pushing the party line. These are that's >> Yeah.
Like it's like the same conversation I had with Rei where it's
like no there isn't. No, there isn't. If I only pay people who
agree with me on nine out of 10 things,
am I paying people to push my opinions, my line, the the JTO
narrative into the world? Yes, I am. Yes, objectively, I don't
have to tell them. They can't talk about the the one out of 10
things they disagree with me on. I don't have to tell them that.
I can just be happy they're pushing the nine out of 10 things
I do agree with them on. >> That's what was the big mischaracterization
here. Like, you can mischaracterization, right? It's not a miscarriage
because you admit that they have people with a particular ideological
bent. >> Yeah. If that ideological bent ranges from I will
suck Joe Biden to I hate Joe Biden. How is that? >> Yes.
That's like do Hold on. Hold on. Most people who hate Joe Biden,
what do you think the most popular politics are? People who hate
Joe Biden. Soy pill. Do you think that's something they're looking
for that the the Ben they're going to get the average person
who hates Joe Biden in there? Probably not, right? Probably not.
So what I'm saying is taking contention with the fact that they're
not allowed to talk about something that for example if they
like take anti-abortion stance they're going to get kicked out.
That's not what that's alleging. These are Democratic influences.
They do already push the Democratic party line. The Democratic
Party line if they're allowed to criticize Democrats.
>> Wait, not just criticize Democratic party line
>> Is it the Democratic party line to criticize the party?
>> We disagree. >> Yes. Lots of Democrats criticize
Democrats.
Yes. Is there anything more Democrat than criticizing Democrats?
I actually don't know. I can't name something. What's more Democrat
party than criticizing other Democrats? It's a big tent party.
It's literally a core feature of that party, right? It's a big
tent. You guys disagree a lot and you end up criticizing each
other and you have discord within your party as opposed to the
Republicans being a much smaller party that is much more uniform
in its thought. bring with Democratic policy token components.
>> It's not the DNC party line to criticize the party.
>> There's a lot of people here. Let's give it to Hutch
to respond and then we can let Dickers respond back if he wants
and then we'll get some other people in here. Go ahead. >> There
was there was one of the creators and it's kind of a small sample
size that we know of right now. I think it's like 12 or 13 or
something like that out of 90, right? And out of that like 12
or 13, three or three or four of them were pretty outspoken about
Gaza. In fact, one of them took it to the extreme of uh accusing
Pete Buddha Judge and the Democratic Party uh at large of uh
being complicit in a genocide. If that person was not only in
the program but featured in a picture on the web page,
>> you understand that like Democrats being being complicit
in a genocide is probably like a a fairly popular or understood
or appreciated opinion within the Democratic party like like
basically and within the sorry the Democratic voter base like
Dem voters do believe that the US is complicit in a genocide.
That's like that's actually true, right? I think that annihilates
the idea that this, you know, secretive dark money group was
uh picking people to like gas up the Democrats. >> Well,
wasn't the only wasn't the other person also like trying to get
Schumer to step down? Like that's absolutely not in line with
the DNC. But >> yeah, Brian Tyler Cohen himself was complaining
about the gerontocracy, you know, complaining about Democratic
Party leadership. I mean, like this is just not it's not >> this
is so stupid. This is this is just this is like sophistry.
I don't use the word very often, but it's like actual sophistry.
Um, actually, like in 0.001% of their content, they sometimes
said Joe Biden sucks on this. So, like, how could that possibly
be? Why wouldn't we We'd have to explicitly say they can never
say Joe Biden sucks and that they can never say that Benjamin
Netanyahu sucks. That's the only way you could prove what you
said. No, it's not. No, it's not. Stop lying. That is a totally
position to take. It's a totally
argument to make. Stop. Stop lying. Stop being like a performative
[__] >> congruent with what was characterized
in that article.
>> Okay, but trying to find people who will never criticize
their own party will never criticize members of their own party.
Every person in politics does this, right? You can't do that.
Even if it's I don't think even be preferable parties against
not telling the party line is what you're saying. >> Talk
about their own party. You absolutely are. Politicians criticize
each other. All that they ask is that you're all they're going
to expect is that you're going to talk about general support
for the Democrats, not that you're going to support every single
member of Congress.
>> Towing the line means you do everything following the
polic. >> No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. Do you know Do
you know what towing the line means? It means you're walking
up to the line and making sure you're aware of where it is and
very careful not to cross it.
And obviously because it is a standard thing for Democrats to
criticize other Democrats, obviously the criticism of Democrats
occasionally is not stepping over the line, right? Repeated disingenuous
attacks on Democrats that would probably be stepping over the
line. You could easily tow the line and criticize Democrats at
the same time.
>> Hey, in general, are you leftwing? These are completely
>> only taking a single line from the very beginning of
the article.
Now that you read through the subsequent thing on 630, can you
look up what tow the line means? >> You said that I hadn't
read the article you tried to criticize that I hadn't. >> No,
I said you didn't click on the secondary link and now you don't
know what to the line means. >> So chorus actually hasn't
got anything in their program about being anti-dog money and
neither has 1635. >> I said 1635
with one of the executives.
>> there is no part of towing. So towing the party line
means doing what the party does, right? Accepting the rules of
the party. There is no rule of the Democratic party that says
do not criticize other Democrats. That doesn't exist. So shut
up. >> The executive of the 1630 fund, the guy
>> It's not an aspect of their fun though, is it? What
>> do you mean it's not an aspect of their fund? It's one
guy says something. The Republican party.
>> Okay. Okay. One at a time. Hold on. Hold on. All of
you shut up. All of you shut up. All of you. All of you shut
up. No one can hear you when three people are talking at once.
We have to at least have some order.
>> They're they're so good at You're talking while I'm
talking. Stop. >> Okay. I love everybody on Twitch right
now, but we did three hours on Twitch today. Okay. We did our
Twitch time for the day. All right, guys. So, head over to kick
kick.com/jd.
Head over to kick. Going to be live on kick. Head over to kick.
We're going kick only for the rest of the stream. Okay. Thank
you guys very much for watching on Twitch. Thank you for following.
By the way, guys, real quick before we end, don't forget to go
and throw your Twitch primers at the channel. Okay, Twitch primers.
Any primers. Twitch.tv/jdlk TV/JLK_.
Go there. Give me your primes. All right. Really appreciate you
guys. We'll see you over on kick. Yeah, it's towing is in your
big toe. You're towing the line. You got your toe on the line.
You're towing the line. Okay. We've stopped the Twitch stream.
We're going Twitch only or sorry, we're going kick only for the
rest of the broadcast. All right. This is bad.
Multireaming off. And we're back. >> Use the mi button.
>> I am going. Soy pill. You're doing it too. Let me finish
my point. Okay, I will have to start meeting people if you guys
don't
>> Oh, wait. I might need to get somebody else's perspective
of this because so many times Wick just mutes and he only mutes
on his own end. So the rest of them keep shouting at each other,
but Wick mutes. So Wick Wick doesn't like this isn't taking place
in a channel. So he's not server muting. He's just muting and
they just keep yelling at each other. I don't know why you'd
hold a debate and not have it in a channel so you could server
mute. It makes no
>> Exercise some self-control and wait your goddamn turns.
Dickers, finish your point and then we'll get into it. Okay.
And I will mute the mother who interrupts. Go ahead. >> Okay.
So, I was just making a simple point about like media literacy
and what we're taking on this panel. Right. So, at the end of
the day, I was right. Cor is not part of the chorus platform
to be anti dark money. It's not even part of the 1630 fund to
be against dark money. It's the personal opinion of the executive
of the 1360 fund to be against dark money. That's fine. That's
not what they're going to fund raise on. That's not the organization.
That's the head of the organization, you might say. But he's
not the king, right? These are complex organizations with multiple
people. Their personal opinion that might be worth something,
but no, the advocacy that this campaign is doing is not against
dog money. It doesn't say >> One, I don't believe that
you've read through the medium article from the
>> might be worth something, but no, the advocacy that
this campaign is doing is not against stock money. It doesn't
say it anywhere. one, I don't believe that you've read through
the Medium article from the executive, not just one person, but
the person who helps dictate the entire agenda of the 1630 fund,
her organization, which is a 501c4 nonprofit that advances progressive
causes through advocacy and fiscal sponsorship. We do so using
>> guys, I believe you, dude. There's no way this this
soy pill guy is like, I don't believe that you have heard the
pitch from the most effective show they could have. By the way,
163 fund, give me money, give me money, give me money, give me
money. Let me read this from the 1630 fund. A medium medium article
on the 1630 fund. The 1630 fund is awesome. The 1630 fund is
awesome. Please give me money. Please sponsor me. Please sponsor
me. Please sponsor me. Bro, this is like so transparent. >> The
legal rule book in place today from the executive. Not just one,
I don't believe that you've read through the medium article from
the executive. Not just one person, but the person who helps
dictate the entire agenda of the 1630 fund. her organization,
which is a 501c4 nonprofit that advances progressive cause.
>> Dickers goes, "I don't think this person's a king. They're
the head, but their opinion is important, but they're not like
the king. It's not the opinion of the or necessarily." And this
guy goes, "I don't know if you know this, but she's the leader.
She's the leader of the 1630 fund
through advocacy and fiscal sponsorship. We do so using the legal
rule book in place today. And we are uh donors feel compelled
to give us uh [__] I lost my plot here." The um give
me a second. Let me find this again. Okay. >> What? Hold
on. I Dude, I'm sorry. I was reading the propaganda and I lost
my place in the propaganda. Dude, someone get me the chank rant
about Democrat donors and like the DNC and CNN. Okay. Where he
just let me read the teleprompter. I just want to read the teleprompter.
Don't make me think. I just want to read the teleprompter. Come
on, man.
>> Let me let me go to the second point. Second point is
I never said the chorus was anti-d dark money. I said the 1630
was. So, let me find the passage and read it to you. But first
of all, when you're talking about um
[__] god damn it. Hold on. I got to stop doing two
things at once. Hutch, uh take over for me while I read this.
>> I don't know what to say. Loud noises. >> Hey,
Hutch, you're the resident expert. You've been arguing about
this on Twitter all day. Hush. >> First of all, >> Hutch,
pick it up for me, buddy. Please,
>> God damn it. Hold on. I got to stop doing two things
at once. Hutch, uh, take over for me while I read this. >> I
don't know what to say. Loud noises. >> That's like That's
the most traditionally Hutch thing. I can't think of anything
that just is a microcosm of Hutch more than that. I don't know
what to say. Loud noises.
>> He's 42, by the way. >> Or I guess I can just
respond to it. So yeah, in terms of when it comes to like me
on the road in terms of advocacy, >> yeah, in no part is
it published that it's any part of the platform that they try
and encourage to be against dark money. That's just a true statement.
Now, you might want to add the nuance that the executive of the
fund has a personal opinion that she's against dark money. That's
fine. All my pointers, these organizations don't actually have
it as a part of their program. They're against dog money. And
the reason why I brought that up would >> Oh, is is Dickers
right now? I didn't see this before. Uh-oh. Looks like Looks
like Dickers is uh
not good. Okay. Should we censor Soy Pill right now? Is this
bad to show him on stream while this is happening? The fact that
we want to support it on these organizations isn't being against
dark money, right? What would you spend money on if you wanted
to get rid of dark money in politics?
>> Advocacy groups that would be against dark money. I
don't know what you're talking about. >> Okay. So, yeah.
Okay. In the article, I
stopped. They're going back and forth. Let them go back and forth.
>> So, it says it's a point of emphasis for the group and
its backing of campaign finance reforms that will require it
and other nonprofit groups to disclose donors and potentially
reduce their influence on politics. So, this is not the opinion
of the executive. This is the executive saying our group does
this. Now, if you're No, hold on. Now, if you're saying the executive
is saying lying or misleading about what her group is trying
to do and the >> I would just say if they have a policy
agenda, they might think that, but if it's not in their policy
agenda, I think that's important to put out. >> Group is
completely contradictory to this in their message and you can
show me that somewhere in the 1630 fund like method. Show me
that please. But it appears to me right now. >> Okay. Show
>> unequivocally.
It's not illegal for a 501c4 to publicly disclose who their donors
are. If they're against dark money, they can just disclose it.
>> People want to donate to dark money. >> They're
not against dark money. >> People don't People don't >> If
the donors don't want to get disclosed, they don't have to be
>> Okay, so the donor like every other dog. >> Wait,
I actually think they as a matter of policy don't disclose. I
think it took Pier Midar like explicitly saying, "Look, I donated
money to this to like know that he was a donator, right?" Like
he had to do that. He had to have that principle himself. >> Oh,
dark money. And then the dark money fund is using dark money.
So it would be >> you not see how that's a contradiction
of actual obviously contradiction. The donors wouldn't want to
donate to this thing once it was illegal to answer the question.
Hutch. Go ahead. >> It's again
it is not a contradiction. The reason why people are attracted
to uh donating money to dark money groups is because they can
do it anonymously and not have any fear of being harassed or
whatever in this like current era of you know witch hunts and
and uh harassment and political violence. So the reason like
so 1630 like >> guys guys guys guys listen listen
I just think like if we disclose
money in politics people might get harassed.
H why? Why would I have to tell you about any conflicts of interest
I have? Don't you know that you could harass me?
Don't you What if you What if What if somebody mentions in my
Twitter mentions that I get money from something? That would
be the end of the world. That would be the end. Or I have seen
Mitch McConnell get screamed at in a diner. Mitch McConnell or
some other politician. Okay. In DC because he takes money from
people because he's like a well, he's an important human being
obviously, right? Yeah. People are going to get harassed over
political speech. uh that is what you sign up for to get like
some level of somebody being mad at you. Yes, this is one area
where we have uniformly universally agreed people need to be
held accountable for one their uh what do you call them your
your like associations your
uh what would it be your conflicts of interest you need to be
squeaky clean and you need to operate at like above a standard
level of of ethic if you're going in politics right it is the
you need to avoid the appearance of impropriety you can't just
avoid impropriy
you need to avoid the appearance of impropriety if you're serious
about doing politics Right. It shouldn't just it shouldn't just
be clean. It should appear clean. It you shouldn't be doing things
where people can go, "Ah, I don't know about that, man." No,
I don't know about that, man. Or at least that's what I would
like people to to stretch towards. Maybe that's not possible
with the money stuff right now, but people are attracted to being
harassment.
contradiction. The reason why people are attracted to uh donating
money to dark money groups is because they can do it anonymously
and not have any fear of being harassed or whatever in this like
current era of you know witch hunts and and uh harassment and
political violence. So the reason like so 1630 like collecting
>> defending dark money. >> No, you're doing the
same thing we did before about like stealing a penny to save
the world. Do you understand that? Like if you can solicit more
>> meaning to try and get out of the fact that you contrad
gives a about your crazy moral system where you would somehow
let 8 billion people die by not stealing it. >> Just literally
all you have to do, Hutch, is just say, "Yeah, that that's not
important to me." Just say it's not >> There's nothing
contradicting yourself. >> There is nothing morally inconsistent
about using a tool that is available so long as your enemy is
using that same tool to their like massive benefit.
>> I mean, that might be wrong. I think isn't that like
the
weren't wasn't the world living in like constant horrific oh
what would you call it like despair cuz everybody knew at the
drop of a hat the whole world might get nuked. Wasn't that like
a lot of the Cold War they're teaching kids how to like act if
they ever get nuclear struck? Like yeah, you could say that,
but it's like maybe there's like a different way. Maybe the the
principal could go in a different direction, right? That's just
an insane
that you're not a second point was dickers was >> and I
say that as somebody who like I understand I agree that like
hey if they've got nukes you need nukes. I agree with that, but
I'm saying like I also feel like probably not nuking people is
a principle I'd like to have, but there are reasons that I would
have nukes. You know, it is a bit of a utilitarian thing. You
could just say that like I'm not principally opposed to nukes
just like Fabian did when he was like, I'm not principally opposed
to cannibalism that you say that they were it was factually true.
They're towing the party line. And I asking you now what do you
think towing the line means if according to let's say if I just
Google this and it says accept the authority principles or policies
of a particular group especially under pressure and that is somehow
akin to criticizing them heavily if not calling them complicit
in genocide. I think these things are complet
has have members of the democratic party said that the democratic
party is complicit in genocide. I'd be shocked if they hadn't
at least on a state level that almost certainly has happened
right >> completely contradictory. Can you find me one
influencer who said that the Democratic Party itself, the DNC,
is complicit in genocide, although critiquing particular politician
and not the people who are the heads of it. So the party, >> yeah,
they don't support everyone in the party. It's just that simple.
>> What I'm saying is you can take a very negative influence
from it if you don't want to read the rest of the article. That's
fine. >> Renald Renyald, I want to hear from you, >> Yeah,
it's not towing the party line to ultimately end up saying we
should vote for the Democrats. That's not towing the party line.
When somebody says we're towing the party line, it means that
we are largely like 90%
um in accordance with the with the DNC. Like I'm Oh, then he
agrees that they're towing the party line. Then these influencers
categorically universally tow the party line and there's no example
of one of them not towing the party line. Perfect. Uh I don't
know why this guy's making arguments for the other side of the
debate, but I love this guy. What what an awesome dude. Amazing.
I don't consider myself to be someone who toes the party line
into fact one sec talking about actually having read the article
to it's not tow the party line. It's push the party line. Do
you guys understand that there she said that they were being
paid to push the party line. Not step over like not not step
over any lines. So it's even more of an intense of an and
>> push the party line means in a like positive is is less
restrictive than tow the party line. Tow the party line would
be more restrictive. I think tow the party line is probably something
I for language if you're going to categorize that subheading
that'd be fine because then you could not include the part about
restrictions on cont
to tow the party line as in you can't deviate from it versus
push the party line as in be generally supportive of it that's
actually a lesser statement you realize difference the difference
is one is you just shut up and just let them push their agenda
the other is I am a paid propagandist who must do exactly what
the Democratic party is pushing neither that's not the article
absolutely No, >> that's not the implication of the >> It's
not the header. Dude, >> do you think
this is so easy, right? Cuz you just have Ilan Omar?
Just show me one of these people who's more aggressive than Illan
Omar, right? It's so easy.
Is Ilan Omar a part of the Democratic party?
Do they broadly push the Democratic party line outside of one
issue? Maybe two issues. Yes, they do. Do you think that pushes
the party line? These are Democratic. How could they have phrased
that? Okay. How could How could they have phrased that? That
there's no way that somebody who just wants to read the by line
at the top of the article couldn't possibly misunderstand
>> while still being catchy, while still having like an
attention grabbing headline. What is it? >> What do you
say? Black.
>> Huh? Why? Why do I have to make it catchy? Why do I
have to do There are journalists. Uh yeah, there are journalists
who are trying to like do their [__] crying about
a thumbnail. It's It's just crazy. It's like uh crazy. And unfortunately,
you have to like actually be harsher about this. I I man people
just don't have any standards. They got no standards at all.
>> A little harder. So
people just wait until he starts nodding later on. Okay. Democratic
incubation think happened. >> Okay. Sorry. Can you start
over? Sorry. I was talking over you. >> Yeah. They got
a certain amount of money to be an incubation program. They'd
have daily messaging. They'd have twice monthly advocacy trainings.
Um, and there'd be check-ins for how can how can they can do
their content?
>> Okay. What about that is pushing or towing the party
line. >> They're being they're being okay. They're being
paid. Yes. >> Mhm. Yes. >> Okay. And these are influencers
who support the Democratic party
>> already. Before they get in there, they're pushing the
party line. >> They've been giving daily mess check-ins
>> to help them. Your definition of pushing the party line
is anyone who is >> I don't know if you think anyone who
does messaging that almost universally supports Democrats. Yes.
Yes.
>> Anyone who >> that is pushing the party line.
Yes. Like Brian Tyler Cohen is a Democrat shill. David Pacman
is a Democrat shill. Why the did you get every major Democrat
shill on board with this program to be mentors if you're not
Democrat shills?
Does D does does Brian Tyler Cohen push the party line? Yes.
Is he the main mentor of the program? Yes. Why, dude? These people
are
performatively. Oh. Oh [__] I just clicked forward.
God damn it. Hold on. I just clicked forward for no reason. God
damn it. Hold on. Uh,
Democrat party line.
Hold on. [__] me.
>> These are Democratic influencers. They do already push
the Democratic party line and now they're being paid to do >> The
Democratic Party line if they're allowed to criticize Democrats
>> has nothing to do with the Democratic party line in
terms of [__] We're a little further than this. >> Exercise
some self-control
and wait your >> 2 hours 13. Thank you. Thank you. who
is >> I don't know if you think
>> anyone who's a Democratic influencer
content it's a dumb definition but sure >> listen you can
say that that's a perfectly good summarization especially when
people can scroll down and read the rest of the article it's
totally benign
give it a second maybe let them go back and forth hutch please
>> can can you define the party line what is the party
line >> can I define the party line it's going to be democratic
issue I would say the Democratic party planks for any given election.
That is the party line. The party line becomes more nebulous
in the like uh like between elections, but for whatever election,
whatever the party planks are, that would be the Democratic party
line. Uh you could say just the broad, you know, I would say
the there's probably like some some not barometer, there's some
leeway in positions, but roughly like the Democratic party uh
platforms that by and large all Democrats will support.
What do you mean?
>> Wait, so Gaza overwhelmingly popular the party line?
No. That are overwhelmingly popular. Obviously, Gaza is one of
the most controversial subjects in the recent years in politics.
>> Okay. What about >> isn't that
in power? Would you consider that the party line? >> Say
that again. Sorry.
>> No. In fact, wasn't it the case that Joe Biden had a
mutiny in his party about getting him out? Wait, are you are
you telling me soy pill
that they didn't have a literal mutiny on their hands amongst
financeers like amongst the donor class amongst the actual politicians
and then there was a scramble to see who the era apparent was
going to be in the middle of that election cycle
keeping Joe Biden Chuck Schumer the gerritocracy in power was
that the party
>> um actually there was controversy around that too well
every time you're going to point out an issue where there's controversy
I'm going to point out that there's controversy and so There's
controversy around every polit that's the nature of polit uh
man. Yeah, I I'm starting to understand why all of these people
will defend Destiny.
Okay, cuz as he sounds on a lot of this stuff, holy sh
these guys are so lost without their talking points. These guys
are out to lunch without their talking points. Jesus Christ.
Oh, there's actually controversy around every issue in politics.
Uh, no. I think um like unions, healthcare, there's a bunch of
issues on the Democratic party side that they basically universally
agree on. Holy [__] Everything is controversial.
So, how can you have a party line? Just what are you asking?
Yeah, it's >> there's controversy around you issues that
you will get 90% agreement of Democrats on. So, for example,
climate change, social equity. Hold on.
>> He's listing the 1630 policy platform. Okay, that's
what he's doing right now. I know it. I've read What are the
other ones? Um,
>> racial justice, affordable healthare, voter access.
>> Are these not core democratic issues?
>> Is the standard just trying to get >> Is this
guy not going to answer the question? Are those not core Democratic
>> That's elected or is it pushing popular narratives within
the Democrats? Because when we said like
the party, all you said was you generally support the Democrats
policy agenda. I don't know why you're freaking the out. It's
true >> because your definitions don't make any sense.
Dickers, uh, do you know who >> They do make perfect sense.
Literally, Hutch just agreed with those
>> That's not pushing the party line
>> Of course. >> Have you heard of counterpoints?
>> I have heard of counterpoints. >> Okay. He was
paid by Progressive Victory. Progressive Victory has a mission
to elect progressives. Would you say that he toes the party line?
>> No, obviously not. Question. >> He was hired as
a uh as a what was it? I >> I he was hired as like a red
team person to go and talk about how you could offend like centrist
less with progressive policy, right? >> He was a uh a contractor
to do policy. No, not policy work. He was paid as a contractor
to do security work. >> You think he was the party line?
>> He was paid as a contractor to do to do security work.
>> Democrat party line. >> Okay. Well, he's a Republican.
So like
>> that. Okay. That's a totally different person.
He understands that Progressive Victory and uh Progressive Victory
and
Chorus are very different organizations with very different goals,
right? Like Progressive Victory explicitly engages in electioneering.
Victory is allowed to be way more partisan.
>> Republican. He's a conservative. >> No, he's not.
>> He's a conservative 2024.
He's an anti-Trump Republican. He's a party
What makes him a Democrat? What makes him Republican and not
a Democrat? >> Please. Please, we're not arguing about
Hold on. >> Yeah, exactly. >> We're not. >> So,
he's not pushing the party line. No, >> we're not arguing
today about whether or not counterpoints Also, you could totally
pay one person. If you pay one person to be your opposing voice
within your circle, right, and the rest of the circle all points
in the exact same direction, that one person doesn't disprove
that the overall goal of the organization is to push in one
How would it? That's such a stupid thing to say. >> This
is a Republican or not. That's not >> It's not an argument.
To be fair, he is a Republican. It's just a fact. >> We're
arguing today about whether or not the article a accurately portrayed
what >> like So I would just ask so progressive victory
paid counterpoints to be a part of that. Would you say they worked
in you know they worked towards bettering Democrats? They worked
towards uh like positive outcomes for Democrats. No. Would you
say that an organization that is primarily built to push positive
outcomes for Democrats to push Democratic policy positions to
get Democrats elected? Would you say that's pushing the party
line? Yes, 100%. 100%.
>> Is doing and B whether or not what Chorus is doing is
um okay if it's something we support or don't support.
>> Scott
wants to go in before me. So >> you want to go in to Scott?
Yeah. I'll give it your time to Scott. Go in. >> Yeah,
it'll take like 20 minutes. Yeah, I know. But uh >> well
no I just want to zoom out because like I said in my interest
statement I knew that the people that were going to defend this
um >> dude how
is it that you claim that there aren't key issues that you can
identify as broadly like popular amongst Democrats or that these
are these are broadly like democratic talking points or democratic
issues democratic stances.
They literally come up with a policy platform every presidential
election. They have like the the Democrat policy platform for
that election, right? They do it every election
and those policies are not that far off most elections. >> It's
so
of course you can't is if there is like complete random distribution
of views than Democrats. So >> that's why I was never I
mean
>> that was literally the topic right now. Um, but again
again getting nitpicky
>> I'm actually I'm actually still upset that Soy Pill
was like so so arrogant right there about Whoa, wait paid Connor,
right? Does that mean he toes the party line? They paid him to
be a Republican in their meetings. They paid him to be a conservative
in their meetings. They paid him for his conservative perspective.
You idiot. You just used an example that totally plays against
you entirely because obviously their goals were still in favor
of Democrats. one word as opposed to actually talking about does
it adequately describe the situation and zooming out a little
bit. What I would say is the the real issue here is you're an
average viewer of political content online. You're not super
connected. You go to work a regular job. You don't do this day
in and day out in your life. And you go and you just go through
your YouTube algorithm because the elections are coming up soon.
And like you're like, I don't know [__] about politics.
I should probably like learn a little bit, get back into it for
a little >> I'll be real. I need Hutch to speak for me
to listen to
Fabian. I I love Fabian. Okay, I love Fabian, but he is going
to he's going to Oh, wait, never mind. Hutch, >> you see
all these large accounts that are pushing pretty much what the
Democrat party is pushing. Yeah, there's some issues on Israel
Palestine. Gather some issues about, you know, this specific
old person. Yeah, there's some issues about, you know, Zo
in New York, right? overwhelmingly you have all of these large
accounts that are super popular and and the algorithm is feeding
you these big accounts and it says you know what everybody agrees
on everybody agrees that the Democrats are the good guys. Everybody
agrees mostly with these things. The the oh I'm watch American
Girl doll YouTube videos and they're pushing Democrat talking
points. So obviously even the American Girl doll people know
what this is about. And then those same people are not telling
you that they're getting damn near six figures just to push those
talking points. Even if it's not a specific that's your issue
they're not getting paid to push those talking points. Those
people were getting paid to be mentors in an incubator program.
They were not getting paid to make content about Democrats. I
I'm Nike and I pay Michael Jordan to wear Nike shoes and talk
about how great Nike shoes are everywhere but in terms of basketball.
Okay. He can't wear them for basketball.
Do I want Michael Jordan to be associated Michael Jordan the
basketball player to be associated with my brand for basketball
purposes for like selling basketball shoes to people?
Probably.
Especially there's basically like imagine there's a law that
prevents you from your infinite funding being going towards okay
people using or sorry like paying Michael Jordan to wear your
shoes in like during a game, right? But you pay him to wear them
outside of the game because it's the best you could do. It's
like are you are you trying to associate your brand with Michael
Jordan? Are you trying to have Michael Jordan support your brand?
Yes. Yes, you obviously are. It's like you pay people who only
do political uh content, who only support Dem who who support
Democrats 99% of the time. Are you paying people to push the
Democratic party line?
If you think the answer is something other than yes, you are
stupid. You are you are willfully ignorant. You are I you might
be looking for a paycheck. That might be the most reasonable
explanation. You might just be looking for a paycheck.
>> This is so stupid. They're getting paid money as a part
of a group. That's the entire goal in funded is to push Democrat
talking points. Yes, there's going to be some issues here and
there. What they're doing is they're selecting people that are
Democrats that want to get Democrats elected that talk about
issues that are important to Democrats. Love this Fabian. This
Fabian guy is smart. Oh my god, I thought this Fabian guy was
dumb before. I thought he was like just a totally like I thought
he was his only goal there was to uh take 5 to 10 minutes every
time he could speak to just wax lyrical about
libertarian philosophy. But it turns out when he actually gets
tuned into an issue, this guy's a machine. >> And then
boosting them, giving them more opportunities, giving them money,
allowing them to go full-time, and increasing the popularity
of those messages and making sure that those messages streak,
and then the people don't know that that's where that funding
is coming from. They have this false reality that these are like
such normal issues that even the American Girl doll is talking
about. Taylor, Taylor herself said that there was no evidence,
nothing that she sought to indicate that chorus was uh pushing.
Uh this is going to be another point about only only
negative influence or negative uh incentives. Okay, negative
reinforcement. Well, there's no indication that Chorus engages
in any negative reinforcement at all. They can't legally. They
legally cannot.
Now, should should Taylor have just put restrictions on their
content with no other spec? She could have said restrictions
on on uh she could have been a little more explicit in there
or maybe not included the restrictions on content thing. I think
that's the only part pushing the party line. I'm 100% comfortable
with that. Restrictions on content I think could be possibly
a little misleading but that's the only thing to do like specific
messaging or
engage just engage with the actual
>> Sorry. Sorry. I have to go back and we have to slow
it down because this is the start. Okay. This is the start of
Fabian Liberty caving Hutch's skull in for like the rest of the
platform. Okay,
I this is this is some crazy [__] that happens >> and
increasing the popularity of those >> I don't know I don't
know what Dicker Dickers might have good points like categorically.
Okay, like he he has like him and I align on this like 100%.
So he probably has really good points on the on like the arguments.
Okay, but Fabian is the one who sits here and goes, "Hutch, are
you a moron?" Hutch, do you even know what an argument is? Hutch,
are you you're just a
you're an incurable lout. You're an incurable buffoon, Hutch.
He just sits here talking. So that's what I want. >> Messages
and making sure that those messages stream more seen. And then
the people don't know that that's where that funding is coming
from. >> Oh, sorry. The Sunday point was incurious loud.
Incurious loud, not incurable. Incurable buffoon. Incurious loud.
Those would go together. They have this false reality that these
are like such normal issues that even the American Girl doll
is talking about.
>> Taylor herself, Taylor herself said that there was no
evidence, nothing that she saw to indicate that chorus was uh
pushing them to do like specific messaging or influencing. >> So
[__]
>> he's Marco Rubioing. He's Rubio bot.
Hutch is Rubio. Hutch is Rubio.
Dude, it's a Could you engage with what I'm saying? Well, technically
Taylor Loren said that there is no proof at all that they were
restricted from talking about any specific policy position. Um,
yeah, I know that, but would you engage with the point I made
about how like if you pay people who only push who 99% of the
time push the exact line you want, is it wrong to say that they're
pushing that line? Well, technically Taylor Loren said that they
don't get negatively punished in any way. They don't get punished
in any way for going to certain topics. Yeah, I I know. I know.
Hutch. I know. Do you have any other programming? Hutch. Hutch.
We need an update. I need I need somebody to to hot swap in.
Okay. New code update. Hot. Huffix. Huffix. Huffix. Get get the
bot updated, guys. Hold on. >> Just engage. >> Just
engage with the actual points.
>> He's engaging with the author of the article instead
of what other perfect quid pro. No, this is not madeup. It's
a basic logical
point. Let him respond. can't engage responding to a single [__]
point. He's just going to soy pill. Hutch, go ahead. >> You're
making these >> if he I swear to God if he makes the Taylor
Loren point again. >> I don't know, man. I don't know,
man. >> Maybe Fabian maybe Fabian needed to do this. Okay,
maybe Hatch had to be woken >> These broad claims that
the author of the article herself refutes. She never said this.
Just straight up period. >> You're [__] lying
right now. Now, are >> uh Taylor does explicitly say on
Twitter this exact thing, by the way, that most of these people
appear to be people who have never spoken on Israel or something
like this, right? They bring up the quote later. >> Are
you genuinely, >> if you really want to do your little
like nuh-uh argument, go for it. But that is the >> No,
it's not a nu argument. You're doing the nuh-uh argument. You
haven't actually addressed the argument, >> bro. You're
saying connect the dots, bro. That's not a very
>> no
compelling argument to me. I'm going to talk to you like you're
five. Here we go. I'm going to talk to you like
>> if you get money. >> If you get money, okay,
>> and then you get money from someone that says, "I like
Democrats. I like to give people that push and talk about Democrat
issues money." And then you're getting that money so long and
and that person goes, "I could give this money to anybody. There's
a thousand people that could replace you at any moment, but I
like you because you say the things that I like and I want to
help you. Does that not have an effect on both the algorithms,
the channels that grow and that person's speech any more than
their audience capture that was >> in the presence explain
the presence of creators who were not only >> uh some creators
actually said that the Gaza thing was a genocide. How do you
explain that? How do you explain them being only 99.9%
aligned on the points? How could you possibly explain it? Um
Hutch,
99.9% is my bar, buddy. That's the bar. 99.9%.
I I know you want you want to argue that it has to be 100% or
we've proven nothing, but 99.9 that's good enough for me. Okay,
that's good enough for me. I'm comfy with that. Okay. >> Only
criticizing the Democratic party. They were giving scathing criticisms
of the dem of the the Democrat. >> Yep. This is >> not
only did they criticize them, they said they were like really
old. Chuck Schumer is really old. He's a really old man. Could
you could you possibly support Democrats and think that Chuck
Schumer is a really old guy?
I don't see how you could do that.
>> Explain why they wait. Wait.
Yes. Obviously. Wait, Fabian. Obviously, yes. They're responded
effect and you didn't [__] get you didn't immediately
would be a chilling effect there. What about let me I'm just
saying yes obviously the concern if you're saying is there a
concern when someone is taking money from someone who could only
be paying them because >> this is like Hutch would argue
this. Okay. You call Hutch bald and he's like no no I still have
some hair back here. I still have some hair in the back. Why
would you say I'm bald? I still if I was bald, how could I have
hair in the back of my head? How could I have hair in the back
of my head if I were bald? Uhhuh. Uhhuh. This might not be the
best. This might not be the best point cuz I don't know if Hutch
is actually bald. I can't see the hairline very well. He He is
like sh his H his hair is shaved. I just don't know if he's like
male pattern baldness or not. Does they share an ideology? Yes,
there's always a concern there. And that's why obviously I think
Hutch and I agree probably people should disclose that especially
when it's large sums of money at a certain point because your
audience has an expectation of authenticity and if you're not
if you're lying about it why do you hate Hutch so much? Because
he's a lying loser who makes totally points. He's just a useful
idiot for people who don't want to make these same points. Most
people, by the way, I want you, Stephen Jian, to understand that
the person who was smart on this, the person who was smart was
Destiny. When he sat there like a
unic on his own stream and refused to cut in on Taylor Loren
on anything, that was the smartest play because anything he could
have done along the lines of what Hutch is doing would have made
him look like a complete [__]
But the rest of every everybody else is like, "Thank God this
[__] Hutch is here so we don't have to go and argue
this cuz we would look stupid." Okay, we look really dumb if
we were out here arguing like Hutch is, but Hutch is willing
to fall in all of these grenades for us. Every single grenade
Hutch is on top of it. Let's go. If you're straight up just like,
"Oh, no. I'm not paid. I'm completely authentic." And you find
this money somewhere. There might be coming into question, are
you really on this side or are you just being paid to do it?
But that has nothing to do with what this article is alleging.
This is just the concept of a chilling effect that could exist.
Yes, absolutely. But now let's talk about what the article is
alleging. The fact that everyone is running away with it saying,
"Oh, these people were paid to say this." And I can't believe
I'm going to defend Ted Cruz here, but what's the difference
between Ted Cruz?
Is Ted Cruz paid to shill for Israel? Does Ted Cruz take money
to shill for Israel? Answer is yes. He takes money from Apac.
right
now is the fact that Ted Cruz woke up one morning and a vision
came to him in his head he was going to be the strongest defender
of Israel in Congress. Okay, does that position that he stated,
that totally story he told, does that mean he's not getting paid
to show for Israel? Answer is no. Obviously, he's still getting
paid to show for Israel even if that would have been his position
anyway.
You could say he's being paid to show for Israel even if he decided
he was going to be the goodest [__] in all of Congress.
Okay. Way before he actually got money from Israel. And anybody
who doesn't understand that concept is
>> Who's saying I'm proclimate change and then getting
$10 million and then becoming pro fossil fuel or being no no
no no. It could change how you act in the future. Best example
of this is in fact Israel that the situation in Israel has changed
massively since October 7th,
But political positions in the United States among positions
only amongst Congress people have seemed to not change along
with that change in reality. Now why do we think that is?
My first answer would be hey actually I would expect that to
have to I would expect that to have something to do with Apac
being a massive fun of a ton of politicians.
That would be my first suspicion pro fossil fuel and a big fossil
fuel company saying well cool you're going to do what I want.
Here's $10 million. Obviously, he's going to feel some influence,
but he's not changing his principle based on that. >> Yeah.
Again, I'm you're not addressing the argument because I'm not
saying that these people are are they have these 10 views and
then because is Dicker's having like tech issues or is this me?
No, this is Dicker. >> As they get money, they change two
or three of these views. What I'm saying is is that there's >> the
situation hasn't changed. You just got bullied into changing
your position. Oh, crazy. I thought a of Gazins died. I thought
a Palestinians got killed or something. Oh, was I lied to? Actually,
there aren't a Palestinians who have been killed. Oh, awesome.
Cuz you know what? I'd much rather be wrong about my position
on Israel than have a whole bunch of those people die. A whole
bunch of women and kids die. Thank God I was lied to. And there
aren't like tens of thousands of dead Palestinians right now.
That was
Thank God. Oh, man. That's Thank God. this big pool of money
looking for content creators to push and to and to grow. And
what they're saying is, look, we need people to hit at least
eight or nine of these views
because because that's what's going that's what's going to push
forth. You're never going to get a perfect person. And and both
Taylor and myself are not claiming that they're saying you get
more money if you say the right thing or saying that we're going
to if you change your views, you know, then then then you get
immediately kicked out. what we're saying and what this is stated.
I mean,
>> um I don't even know if I'd call it a genocide at this
point. I think it's stupid to call it a genocide because you
get into an argument over the meaning of genocide, right, with
people who are totally disingenuous and whose only goal is to
obiscate around the meaning of genocide. I would say just say
like want and slaughter, want and slaughter Palestinians. That's
what's going on right now,
right? I don't I don't know if I want the genocide thing there,
but it's like a totally disgusting amoral process that's taking
place. Ethnic cleansing absolutely yes. I think by anybody's
definition in ethnic cleansing it's like so disgusting
right that's all I have to say about it >> somewhat vaguely
I don't like Taylor obviously like anybody that knows I'm not
a Democrat right like I don't I don't like social justice anti-
capitalist believe but nevertheless yes there's some there's
a there's a tinge of yellow journalism there but the overall
argument is true and the argument is that when you have a bunch
of dark money that people don't know about and when you have
people. >> Uh, give me a second. I'm going to go uh I'm
going to go get uh something to eat real quick. I'll be right
back. I'm just >> It's getting funded by this dark money
that that changes the way that that that either a can can have
a chilling effect on their speech or at the very least b all
of that money can just pick a new person. And so those messages
get paid for and they get paid for in a secret clandestine way.
And so that normal people watching don't recognize that these
ideas aren't necessarily popular. >> We got to break down
your argument. So
one is the paid for, one is the secret part, and then then the
one is the chilling effect, right? So would you say I'm paid
to be a Democrat? >> Would you say I'm paid to be a >> I
don't I don't know your I don't know >> I'm a progressive.
Would you say I'm paid to be a It's my full-time job now. Am
I paid to be a progressive? I mean, in in a certain manner of
speaking, you're you're you're paid to do the content that you're
doing for your >> right? And I don't think this is a gotcha,
by the way. I think yes, 100%. My audience, if I became well,
if I became MAGA tomorrow, I would lose my entire audience. So,
there there's always going to be I have my principles and it
would just completely like if I shifted those, I'm not going
to get this money. So, yeah, I'm worried in so far as if for
some reason I thought MAGA was the solution, I would become just
financially ruined. Okay. But the secret part I think is the
more important part. >> These people are not being paid
in secret. Chorus was very open about this about the program
and how this is working. A bunch of people are disclosing, hey,
I work with Chorus. Donate to Chorus. I'm part of this incubator
program. So some people are still secret. They have not released
the names of all these creators and there might be privacy reasons
for that. And I do think that hey, if you are being paid, especially
to make content about a political issue, you should probably
say you should probably say this was paid for by this hack or
whatever. >> That's not actually true. >> No, no,
no. I agree with you that there are some of these people that
are kept secret and that might be because of privacy or they
don't want what is happening now which is you know I don't know
if you've seen the [__] smear campaigns coming out
against some of these people that have their names released like
it's pretty bad and I know Taylor herself has said I'm not releasing
the contracts because >> the secrecy not against the secrecy
>> this is my argument for the fact that they're not with
releasing all the names but I'm agreeing with you that there
is always going to be a chilling effect when you receive money
from anyone for anything. Yes. though what are you alleging was
wrong specifically in this case of that because if you're saying
>> yeah after you >> giving any money period is not
>> no it's not about giving money period it's about having
an obligation based on receiving that money you have you have
accepted obligations you sign a contract that is something you
should update your audience on you've agreed to certain conditions
and you've accepted money for that not from your audience you
should update your audience on that you should be transparent
on it especially if it's for political speech >> okay then
I can contend with that but if you're Just saying this specific
kind of giving money wasn't okay because some of these people
didn't disclose that they were getting money for an incubator
program. I think that's total non-issue. >> Well, to be
clear, the incubator program was not public. Chorus, the project
was public. The incubator program, that's what the article is
about. The incubator
program wasn't about >> the incubator program. >> Chorus
was a bunch of creators. They the newsroom was part of that.
But in terms of like the daily messaging thing, the adequacy
training, the payments being given to people in the incubator
program doesn't mean the incubator program wasn't part public.
>> Wait, it wasn't public.
>> You made fun of him for not reading the >> Okay,
maybe I maybe I'm doing a reading comprehension gaffu. Now, let
me double >> So, there's two. There's chorus the the overarching
program and then the 16 uh 30 fund as part of like a subgroup
project was the chorus incubator
>> Okay. These are two different this is a two different
things. I mean obviously they're under the same people in terms
of BTC but but these are two different programs. So the overarching
chorus program was something that was open that they were talking
about etc. The chorus incubator program was the one that people
were signing contracts for where they were saying you're not
supposed to tell people. I mean granted that's one example and
we have to trust Taylor. So that's like two reasons of why it
might not be fully true, but nevertheless, presumably the contracts
that were sent out were saying you're not supposed to tell people
that you're in this program and that was the one that had additional
that was >> so this is the difference between unironically
the best example of this the best like parallel to this is just
Taylor Lorenz's program right with Omidr. I would say it's like
very very closely parallels. You just go and you try to explain
that to people, right? Taylor Lorenz's thing with Omdar. Obviously,
the journalists, the journalist and residence program is different
from the Omidar group.
The Omdar group is something that exists to to like create programs
like this to help people, right? And Chorus has a mission, but
it is different from the the explicit incubator program that's
funded by 1630 >> was the one that was directly paying
>> So, I'm confused because some of these people did say
they're part of this program before her article. So obviously
it's not saying it was saying you should go through >> I
thought it was the incubator program but if these are completely
separate entities as you're now saying maybe I've completely
misunderstood this so the incubator program >> I wish I
wish these guys had thought to do the Taylor Ren thing right
>> I think that's just way easier to explain to people
given that you have to know the Taylor Ren thing to to do the
talking points they would already be engaged with this it would
be very easy to explain that way
>> started up back in November >> hold on hold on
I do want to get prime Kai in here He's been waiting a little
bit. Okay. >> Can I just add one point? >> One point
quickly. >> Okay. So, if you go to the course >> free
pie in this case, I don't necessarily agree. Free pie says the
amount of people who are just like that's a legally binding contract
and not something they'll actually enforce. They only mark you
make you sign that to benefit them if you sign a contract like
that you're expecting the terms to be binding or if you Yes.
So, you'd be a mark if you think otherwise. Right. Now, I do
think that actually in this case, they're probably not really
looking to enforce it. They'd actually probably I think they're
Here's the thing.
They're making you sign a contract where you agree not to do
the things they want you to do. They want you to endorse Democrats.
They want you to election. They just don't want you to tell them
about it. They want to pay for those things without being accused
or without being held liable for paying for those things. So,
they're like, "Actually, don't disclose that you're getting paid
by us. Don't do it. Don't say anything about us because as long
as we're just paying you under the pretense of being pro-democracy,
you can you can take all of this money and do all the electioneering
you want. Just don't do it with our logo on your
so I actually think in this case they might not do it. But to
me that's just that's the best case scenario is they just want
to violate campaign finance law as aggressively as possible.
>> Website uh I know soy pill you said that you wanted
to or you have signed up for it. I think you're not signing up
for the incubator program. You're signing up to be part of chorus.
Okay. So, you can't apply to be part of the incubation program.
They reached out to creators, but yeah, that's the one point.
>> What are you applying to be when you're in chorus then?
>> A part of chorus.
Look, not part of the incubator program. >> What does what
does outside the incubator program >> marries people politicians?
>> No, Chorus has a mission statement and they create programs
and direct funding to accomplish those goals. Their goals are
things like aligning Democrats on me messaging, getting Democrat
politicians who are sort of behind in the in the digital age,
more involved with independent creators. They have a couple different
goals as chorus. And Chorus is the group overall that creates
programs and centralizes funding to pursue those goals. But uh
I don't know why we didn't we didn't have this like these abstractions
thought of before.
I I uh I shouldn't just circle dickers because nobody did. It
seems like
um I shouldn't just circle tickers. This is uh it's probably
something tough to think of on the fly. >> It's for like
media interviews
like they were doing that before the incubator program existed.
>> So forming a network of people and also the incubator
program is for the smaller
>> Yeah. To pay them and stuff like that. >> I mean
if David Pacman is one of the smaller creators
in order to join the incubator program >> relationship
but anyway I want to give it to Prime Kai. He's been waiting
a little bit. Go ahead.
>> So, they're aggressively violating campaign finance
law. I think what they're doing is they're paying for political
speech, including speech they know will be like election engaging
in electioneering and like hyperartisan,
but they're doing so under the pretense that they would prevent
people from doing that.
They're saying, "Don't disclose that you're partner bias. We
don't want to pay for these messages. We just want to you we
just want to pay you to figure out how to set up your ring light.
Okay? That's what we're paying you for. Don't don't talk about
us. We're just paying you to set up your ring light." And it's
like, okay, but you're paying you're paying somebody $8,000 a
month to learn how to set up their lighting
when you know that they'll engage in electioneering. You know
that they'll be hyperartisan for Democrats. They have been in
the past. They will be going to the future or you can just like
not pay them if they are in the future. It's obvious what you're
paying for and it's not to teach them how to set up their lighting.
It's not to teach them how to set up an LLC. It is obviously
for something else.
That's what you're paying them for in my opinion. But again,
difficult to prove. >> And uh you know, I haven't met um
>> actually
not even really all that difficult to prove. When you look at
Ali 202, Ali O'Brien, you look at her response to all of this
and it's like, no, I'm allowed to do whatever I want or say whatever
I want. They just don't want their their logo on it, right? It's
like, oh well, we're going to pay somebody who only does political
content in favor of Democrats like 99.9% of the time.
But we're not paying to support Democrats. We're not paying to
push Democratic party messaging. We just have messaging check-ins
that are super lean Democrat. We just we only have like advocacy
trainings that's super lean Democrat and we're paying people
who 90 99%
of the time support Democrats.
That's all. Come on, guys. Why are you acting like Why you acting
like I'm trying to support Democrats here? Why you acting like
I'm trying to push the Democrat party line? Come on, man. >> Very
brief. Sometimes they're five minutes. Then three times a week
in the >> Oh, whoops. Wrong video. Wrong video. Back to
that. >> Side point. I haven't met this dick person before,
but their voice is wonderful. I love it. It's even elegant when
they call someone a >> Oh, Apollo's Heights. I'm saying
they're paying and then saying, "Actually, we're we're making
you sign a contract that makes you check in with us to make sure
you're not going to violate any laws." Right. But they don't
expect you to check in. And the people who do represent them
have said, "No, no, no. We'd never enforce this." So you, even
if you check, we'd never enforce this. Right? They don't want
to be associated. They don't want to be paying for your individual
content so they don't get they don't run a foul of this. They
have clauses in their contract that says you can't disclose this
and we don't want to be paying to do these ads for you. Right?
They have all of these things set up explicitly in my opinion
to get around campaign finance laws.
And what they're paying for is political speech and it should
be subject to those laws. But maybe Republicans do it too and
you can make some argument about uh like an arms race, right?
>> It's a it's beautiful. Um but um uh I um
going back to uh whether this article
um was accurate. I was going to have a different angle from what
you guys were discussing before. Um like >> nothing even
close to violating the letter or spirit of the FC laws. Well,
I think they have to be a nonpartisan pack.
They need to be nonpartisan, Joe Bro. And I think the essence
of it in spirit, they are a hyperartisan pack. So, I don't know
why you'd say that they're not violating the spirit of FEC laws
when by definition they're supposed to be nonpartisan. They're
clearly
>> Uh uh people have said uh that this article, you know,
um takes pieces of the contract and paints them in a uh a bad
light that in in actuality in the in the practical running of
the organization, it's different. But um I just want to point
out that uh Taylor, unless of course she lied, uh like reached
out to the creators who are actually part of the program. Um
she gave them a chance to comment and then they roundly did not
comment on the on the story. And
yes, Rick Shelly, campaign finance laws do apply. Packs are literally
super PACs are literally not allowed to coordinate with campaigns.
They pay for advertising.
what what they're doing with these people if they were pay if
they were like on their books honestly they'd be paying for advertising
>> and to paint it uh and I don't want to put exactly these
words in the mouth of the opposing team here but to paint it
as um uh this is a dishonest or or um
>> by the way there's a knockon effect to this give me
a second I got to finish this mouthful I cut some salad here
okay there's like a a knockon effect of this
by announcing this, by getting to this big controversy, they're
putting up a huge flare into the air. Okay? Huge flare into the
air. Guess what, guys?
If you support the Democrats, like 100% if you're a total Democrat
shill, you might make thousands of dollars a month. We might
call you up and pay you thousands of dollars a month. You don't
think there's going to be a shift in some people's content just
a little bit to be like, I actually love Democrats.
I actually I'm I look at this IRA. I'm going to be just like
this IRA guy. You don't think there's a flare going up in the
air at all with with this kicking off so massively on social
media? These people are just like, "Oh, actually, I forgot. I'm
I'm actually like totally on the Democrat side here. I actually
love these guys.
$8,000 a month. I love Nancy
I love Chuck Schumer. Oh my god." >> A poorly worded uh
view of uh how this program works. It's like, well, okay. Well,
I she did reach out continuously um to the creators to the organization
and for the most part she got nothing back, right? Um and it
it seems like uh for people on this side and again I don't want
to put this necessarily your mouths but like it seems like um
>> wait wait I'm sorry K this guy in chat dickers you just
said find the word incubator. It is the fourth word on the paragraph
that I just posted. The only thing you're applying for is the
incubator program. You're >> I just spit Oliver's martyr.
It's the first word on the page. It's the first word on the page.
chorus incubates.
>> Oh, that's the particular program. Well, that's the
particular program in the >> We are chorus. That's what
it is. >> Yeah, that's not the main chorus website though,
is it? >> Yes, it is. >> Don't believe a little uh
Destiny performative spuring.
Act like an adult. Option A, act like an adult. Option option
B, act like a petulant child who's sping the out. This guy's
picking B immediately. BB
B. Yeah, exactly. Moonray Murray. Okay, hold on. We are chorus.com.
We are chorus.com. And I'm going to go to a little a little little
thing here. Okay. Called the internet archive. Let's see when
they announced the incubator program. We arecorus.com. It looks
like we have snapshots from what the 27th of August. And then
before that, it is the 15th of May is the snapshot before that.
So look, 27th of August. Hopefully somebody thought to snapshot
this in between, but I don't know. We are chorus.
We are chorus. Uhoh. Donate.
It should be the FAQ page, right? Oh, right here. Yeah, FAQs.
Hold on. We want FAQs, I think. I think that's what we want.
We want the FAQs, right?
Am I crazy? What is the application like to become an incubator
member? Let me see if we can find the FAQs page. Can you Can
you just work? Maybe. How about you just work? Uh oh. FAQ's page
only has an archive on the third.
Interesting. I don't see anything for any of these things that
are showing the FAQ's page, which is weird.
Get in touch and mission. This is in May. They didn't have an
announcement of the incubator program. And do I have another
Where do I have my other stuff here?
27th. We've got to have We've got to have this, right? 29th.
Let me open up one more snapshot from the 27th.
This is the 27th.
We only have get in touch. I don't see anything else up here.
It's just get in touch. Do we have the frequently asked questions
or did that FAQ get added hastily after the article popped? I
don't know. It sure seems like possibly hastily after the article
popped is what it is. Join Chorus. Get in touch. Join Chorus.
On this point, we have join Chorus here. Uh, nothing right now.
Rick's jelly, I don't think I don't think you could get caught
for electioneering right now cuz it's not election season. It's
not like really started yet.
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on.
This is the This is the 20
What is this? This is the 29th they had the incubator period.
Uh, join chorus. Okay, they had this at the bottom for join chorus.
So, I need to go back to an earlier version. I've got this 29th.
Do I have 27th here somewhere? 27th. There's get in touch, but
there's not a join chorus. So join chorus appears to come in
unless I'm mistaken
>> appears to come in between August 26th and August 29th.
>> Chorus is for the folks. You think malarkey wins elections?
Not a joke. Chorus means
uh look just give me a break here man. >> Just give him
a break here man. Come on man. Join chorus.
Then at the bottom of the the join chorus page there's an FAQ.
It looks like this. So we look at the dates on join chorus. Let
me look at this. The join chorus page has archive links for when's
the first one. It appears August 27th is the first time the join
chorus thing comes up. So like right as the article is dropping
or right as it dropped this join chorus page gets added right
as best we can tell from internet archive and [__]
So it's not like they were disclosing it before the incubator
thing is same day as the article. Okay. So, I listen, it's nice
to be able to do this cuz we're not in the middle of a debate
here, but it's like it's so obvious what's happening, right?
Oh, look. I can go to their website and it says everything about
this. No, it doesn't. Says it after the article comes out. Come
on, man. It's But but they'll reach for these things and they
won't even do like this is the first thing I thought of, right?
I don't want to just say some This is my thought process. I'd
like to figure out what the truth is here. So, I'm going to go
look for some information that gets me the truth. What these
guys do is they go to the website and they go, "Is there any
proof that they referenced the incubator program before this?
Oh, there's incubator the word incubator on the site. Oh, look.
It's proven. I won." And he just spams it out immediately.
Like, isn't
why what makes your thought process like this? I don't get it.
I don't get it. Oh, wait. No, I do get it, actually. He's putting
up the flare himself. Chorus, look, Chorus, I'm willing to shield
totally disingenuously for you,
>> Can I get 8K a month, Chorus? TLK sounds like a droid
name. Is that not a joke? Is that a Star War? Chorus is the good
guys, man. Not a joke. Thank you very much, Joe. Sleepy Joe.
Come in with the 10 bucks. Let's go.
Liberalism is a mental disorder. No, I don't think so. But I
Dude, it's got to be tempered with some values, man. You got
to have some values. Take a position first, then look for the
evidence. Well, I I'll be honest. I had a position first, but
I don't want to look like a and state something that's totally
wrong. So, like I have a position that like I don't believe they
disclosed it. I believe that based on how they've acted that
they weren't disclosing this. Can you really say it's not a private
program if and can you really say they're trying to hide it if
they have a web page that talks about it that was published after
the expose that showed that they had a hidden program?
Hello. Can you really say that? Do you really think it's appropriate?
Do you really think you're being fair right now? I don't think
you're being fair right now. I'm doing like the sassiest head
sways, by the way, that you guys can't see. executive, not just
one person, but the person who helped the entire agenda of the
1630 fund, her organization, which is a 501c4 nonprofit that
advances progressive causes through advocacy and fiscal sponsorship.
We do >> I just clicked the wrong Yeah, I knew I just clicked
the wrong video cuz this isn't the
incubator program.
Click on join chorus. It is the incubator program. You have no
idea what the [__]
creator incubator is a particular is a particular program within
the chorus organization.
>> Okay. What is join? The only thing you can join is the
incubator program. >> Send me the web page cuz I haven't
I haven't actually seen this web page.
The judge
I can finish your point, but DM me the web page. I'm really curious
>> Sure. Um, adjust that. >> This is for the incubator.
>> I'm back where I was, but um I'm sorry.
>> No, no worries. No worries. It's fine. Um, yeah. >> We
talked to multiple people and didn't get responses. Sort of frame
it in a negative light. Um, >> yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think
it's this has to do that. Like this >> has a Wikipedia
article right now and it
>> honestly underscore on the part of Chorus.
I'd say on a scale of 1 to 100, it's like a five or a six, but
that is almost all in their PR.
In terms of like what they got caught doing and what they had
to answer for with no response at all, it's like a three to me.
It's like a three out of three. A three out of 10. Three out
of 10. A 30 to me. their response has been so disingenuous and
the people who have been arguing on their side have been so
that like they they've racked it up to like a seven or an eight
now where they're just they're just acting totally disingenuously
totally disgustingly right. There's like no thought towards
>> Cohen is also the co-founder of chorus creator incubator
program. So I I'm not seeing what you're seeing in terms of uh
>> so Hutch is reading from the Wikipedia with no concern
about Listen guys, I'm just trying to point I know my position.
I'm going to try to push a position. I'm going to do whatever
I can to do that. It's transparent. It is just transparent shilling.
And for Hutch, he's not getting paid by chorus. I don't even
know what I don't even know what Hutch is doing. Hutch is just
like the Lenny for liberals right now. Like he's just he's going
to go crack some pretty little necks for them. be completely
like he's gonna have no idea what's going on. He's just Lenny,
okay? He's gonna go break some necks. He's gonna go kill some
some progressive bunnies for them. And then when he's done his
job, when it's time to put them out of the pasture, they'll do
it with no they'll do it with fewer tears than George did. Okay.
It's going to be over. >> Uh there being like a separate
chorus. >> The the incubator program is a program within
Chorus,
the organization. >> It's the Hold on. Look at the article.
It says Cohen is also the co-founder of the chorus creator incubator
program. I think what uh Zoyel is saying is that the incubator
program is baked into
>> What's fundamentally it's a part of chorus? Yeah. >> Yeah,
it's a part of
>> like the way that the McDonald's training program for
new employees is part of McDonald's. >> The chorus incubator
program existed. >> What did it do? >> It uh >> well
this is this is the stuff that came out in April. I think the
incubator program is their first major program. They were fundraising
to like
and create awareness and get like their their page up that says
they have 5,000 small money >> right? American creators
with politicians so they get interviews >> like like when
they went to an event, right? And and so I was right. This isn't
the main website. I don't know if it's a mischaracterization,
right? >> If you go to the main website for donation, it
says chorus is a creatorled nonprofit organization dedicated
to helping content creators expand their reach and educate their
audience about news and public policy issues that impact their
lives. founded by a group of content creators in December
2024.
>> I do wonder when that was uh do we have do we have other
things about Chorus? Can we can we see what their mission statement
was? When did they get a mission statement here? Well, I got
a bunch of archive links here. This is May.
Get in touch mission. Can I see their mission from May? There's
their mission from April. I just want to see what it is. I I'd
just be interested to
April the mission in as of April was April 26, 2025. Will this
page load? It is kind of loading. I got some colors. I'll go
back to the debate. Is recruiting train
incubator program.
>> That's not the incubator program. >> You guys
You guys are making fun of you didn't read the article or like
watch >> Well, to be clear, >> when did the incubator
program start? >> What you just said?
>> When did the incubator November of last year, right?
No, it didn't. >> This is the first cohort. It's a six-month
program. How does that work? >> You can imagine if they
were starting this program. >> No, I got an answer to that.
Sorry. >> Hang on. I'm answering I'm answering your question.
You can imagine if the goal was to do this thing of building
up smaller creators. It would take some time to onboard like
bigger creators before you actually kick off the program in earnest.
>> That's not you wouldn't just you wouldn't just snap
your fingers and then >> that page didn't load with their
>> All of a sudden, it's like boom, now we got our thing.
These are two different things. Okay. This isn't >> the
chorus creator community
is the main thing and then the incubator
>> is to get in. >> Yeah. Thanks, Kacophanies. I'm
going to go over that those documents myself in just a little
bit and maybe we could look at um potentially criminal stuff.
Guys, don't forget if you like the content, make sure you follow
us on every platform. Follow on Twitch, Twitter, okay? X.com/jlk
Join the Discord. discord.gg/jstlk.
All right, join up. Join up. Join up.
All right. Wait, what? Why did I get sent these logs? Um, also,
I'm gonna Yeah, Twitch primers, subs, donations, more time on
the stream. We need so many hours on the stream today to get
through all of the topics. So, guys, it's really important you
donate, okay? Get more hours on the stream. What are these logs?
I just got sent these logs. Going to be honest, I do not keep
up with JTOK or any of the antivan stuff. I understand that Destiny
talks about them because he's correcting the record. I don't
pay them or KF any mind because they are aren't worth my time.
I will say that JSTO being silent about this could be good news.
Sorry, just that JTO has been slow to respond to the recent filings
could be the sign of a the jerk wave starting to eb.
Oh
no, I just wasn't streaming.
You're not snarking hard enough. I mean, I'll cover the recent
filings, but like that's just cuz it's of interest to people.
It's not cuz I like it's not it's like of interest to the audience.
By the way, I just laughed that in terms of the filings and stuff,
I'm like starting to realize
that I might be the greatest legal scholar of our age. Okay,
I I might accidentally I'm like the I'm like the Mr. Magcgoo
of legal scholarship. I was just like, hm, seems like Destiny's
making things up right now, but I can't say for sure. And all
of the things he said, oh, they're going to um they're going
to totally they're totally going to um
oh, what's penalize like Pixie lawyers? They're totally I think
the court might actually throw this out themselves. I think I
think the court might actually throw this out themselves. And
the guy's like, "If you want to get it thrown out, you just like
go and apply for that." Like, why would we do it? I just I think
it's so funny that all the things I said are coming to pass.
Which, by the way, never included Destiny losing massive amounts
of money on this. But that might be the wrong the one place I'm
wrong. I I might actually be wrong in that I didn't think Desi
was going to get a solid judgment against him in this, but that
might be it's looking like that could be the one place I was
incorrect. Oh, look. They they totally have granted a bunch of
Pixie stuff around privacy. They've totally like Destiny's a
total He's He's like uh what is it? He's like a child again here.
He just breaks the rules for no reason
to pay Andy B more money. He's like the biggest Andy B pay.
Like, say what you want about Prince Andrew and these other guys
who actually had really serious accused they were accused of,
right? At least they shut the up while Andy B did his job. Destiny
goes out here all the time just being like, I dude, Andy B doesn't
get paid enough. I got to make this way harder for him. Let me
go on some random stream and read the transcript that's sealed
verbatim. Let me try that. Maybe that's a good idea. You content
creators, small creators.
>> Chorus. Chor course is a fund. Okay. And that fund uses
to like set up meet and greets. They were able to get the people
into that into that building where they thought they might be
getting interviews with politicians, but it turns out they weren't
necessarily getting interviews with those politicians. But then
when Taylor Lynn reached out to them uh to BTC, he said that,
you know, we had gotten 53 million views and so we had gotten
more views from that program than than um than like the major
news media had gotten on Donald Trump's
course. Is there
>> 1630 is the fund just anything that has money is not
a fund. >> This is a specific program with a specific goal
to specifically incubate
>> No, it's not. >> Yeah. This is my god chill. >> Again,
I'll go back to my question. Okay. This started in December.
>> It's a six month program. >> You can just go look
at Brian Tyler Cohen's thoughts. Uh supporting creators and giving
creators resources was a part of it, but it was not the only
part. I don't think it was the main part. Graham, it's now September.
How are we still at the first cohort?
>> Because you don't start on day one when it's created.
That's how it works. Look, I don't know. I've taken part in some
of
>> I I would say the same thing about you. >> so
they found just like immediately incubating people and then for
6 months they did nothing except that they went says they're
going to go defend destiny on Kiwi farms. Good luck. Good luck.
and then they get a bunch of money and they're like, "Cool, let's
do our pilot program." This is like
>> uh of what I know of null. Okay. Seems like his one
line is
like he hates
I don't know why you'd go to like an al-oging forum as a known
admitted I don't know why you'd do that. That's crazy to me.
I don't think that makes any sense, but I wish them the best.
>> The incubator program is a program that they do. It's
not the main organization. It's not the purpose of the >> Hang
on. Hang on. >> It's one of the purposes. Sure. >> The
FAQ. >> What is the main purpose? >> The very first
thing on the FAQ
are the benefits of >> helping content creators expand
their reach and educate their audiences about news and public
policy issues. Think about their lives. The primary one is to
be a middleman between creators and political figures.
>> He asked me a question and then Hutch jumped in. >> Get
your point out. Hutch was talking the whole time. What are the
benefits of joining Chorus? That's the first question. And then
it says, "Corus' incubator program is a vibrant pro-democracy
learning community." If Chorus was like a separate thing from
the incubator program, why do they describe themselves first
and foremost literally leading with the incubator program? >> What
did I say like 10 minutes ago? The McDonald's training program
is a part of McDonald's. It is a program that the organization
carries out. >> Does Chorus make burgers too? Is that like
do they have a separate thing they >> They might rather
this guy. Dude, I didn't realize when when Connor was doing this.
Okay, remember when Connor was on that panel with Pisco and Destiny?
What was that about? Oh, whether or not to cut lefties off. I
didn't realize like so many people engage in that behavior. Did
I just not see this before that this guy's just like transparently
trying to muddy the waters here? Do you remember when Dan came
on my stream right after the the Pixie and and Cherry stuff broke
in in January and he was like, I'm just here cuz I don't want
to let Mr. Girl talk. That's like at least Dan was honest about
that. Okay, that's what these guys want. Like I just want to
make sure that these guys don't speak. I just want to like be
a like a buffer over here. Okay, I'm just gonna like I'm just
going to be a total [__] and you're going to focus.
I'm going to be like a sorry a magnet. I'm just going to get
everybody to hit me cuz I'm going to say really dumb [__]
and you'll never actually talk about the >> I do for how
much you seem to know. I don't know. >> Is a program that
the organization >> Got to listen to that whole insult.
Does Chorus make burgers too? Is that like do they have a separate
thing they do? >> They might do for how much you seem to
know. I don't know.
>> I I think >> that's his response. Yes, I am totally
right now. >> Very obviously implying that all the way
back in December they were trying to marry creators with politicians
so that they could get create political content. They're trying
to be a middleman between creators and politicians to facilitate
those interviews that type of content. Yeah. Also, a few months
ago, they started the incubator program, which is a new program
that they are now doing.
>> Why did Brian Tyler Cohen, when he was first talking
about founding this like way several months ago, I think back
in November, why did he describe this as a program to uplift
like smaller creators?
>> Um, well, I think they did want to do that through mentorship,
through through providing resources. I'm not totally sure what
he meant. Okay. But I do know that Brian Talico had interest
in in funding uh or sorry providing resources to creators to
relieve them of financial burden so they could just create their
content. Whether or not that was through paying people to help
them with stuff, paying like editors and people to clip their
or whether that's through directly giving them money doesn't
matter. He he did express like the idea of giving them some amount
of uh financial or logistical support. Okay, >> that just
wasn't the only thing and I don't think that's one of the primary
focuses of chorus because they would get access to politicians.
>> Part of the goal. >> Why didn't he start the incubator
program then? You might say that was always his intention, but
they are still separate, right? They were not just mentors and
then
it's an entire larger organization. I don't know why we're getting
so stuck on this point. >> I need to concede something
to dickers before we because we can move on from this. Fabian
go ahead please. I just Okay. If all you're saying is that the
incubator program specifically, as in like the way that people
join is separate from the fact that some of the people affiliated
with Chorus don't participate in the thing that like, hey, we're
teaching you to make thumbnails like, "Hey, David Pacman, you
might be a mentor in this. We'll also uh reach out to this one
politician or something and let you talk to them." Okay, they
do that as well.
>> No, it's an incubator program. No, before the incubator
program they had Kors had um at least according to Taylor Loren
and according to their own um you know like I don't I wrote it
down in my notes so I didn't give you a link because I feel like
you're going to ask for a link for everything but go watch Taylor
Loren's video she showed where they were doing the Zoom call
meeting where they had bragged before they >> uh Wick does
want slop content. He doesn't want like an effective conversation
at all. Slop content is way more enjoyable. Okay, just people
screaming at each other that's way more enjoyable for everyone.
If I wanted actual meaningful conversation, I'd go look for like
actual policy experts, actually well- read people who argue on
these things. I try to be well read, but I'm not really well
read on any specific issue that I'm like an expert, right? Instead
of maybe like I I don't even know if I'd say I'm an expert in
like anything necessarily. I I would say for like some compai
topics, I could have been an expert like three or four years
ago. I I I think I could have been an expert, but like at this
point, like I'm probably not a super expert on like anything.
If I wanted to have a very effective discussion, I look for like
one-on-one discussion between two experts in a field. I don't
look at panels. Panels are slop content for the piggies. Okay?
Slop content for the
They created the >> as as our our best buddy tech >> um
incubator program of of working with the DNC and impactual LLC
to be able to host a Zoom meeting that was sponsored by Chorus
of all of the DNC candidates. They were doing other things.
it they were hosting like a discussion with all of the DNC candidates
uh leading up to the to was it one of the elections for the um
for one of the DNC election leadership elections. >> Okay.
As long as we can all agree that this is clearly trying to get
creators to expand their reach without telling them what to do
then that seems to be >> I think you've forgotten the original
point. So the original point of this is that people disclosed
that they were a part of chorus. There was not disclosure that
the chorus incubator program existed or that people were part
of the incubator program or getting paid as a part of the incubator
program. This is the point. >> Getting paid to participate
in the trainings is different from getting paid to do any of
the other stuff. All of which are purpose on your re combo right
now. I don't know why. Uh I also don't know why, but I'm good.
>> The stipens are for the incubator program. We don't
know that David Pacman's getting played. He hasn't claimed that.
David Brian Taylor Cohen isn't getting paid. I know. I know he's
a volunter. >> You made the claim that it was proof that
that there was that there wasn't secrecy about being in the program
because that people had already said that they were a part of
Chorus and then we had to explain to you and you went through
this semantic storm because you're so bad faith that you we had
to finally nail you to the wall that these are two different
things and that it can be true that someone could say I'm working
with Chorus. I'm a part of chorus but not necess but and also
true that the chorus incubator program was a was a portion of
that that had aging
that said you're not supposed to talk about this. >> Yeah,
we've said enough. >> So if you have you guys seen the
Ali O'Brien video where she says that I was part of chorus before
any of this happened and that there was implication that there
was payments received as in some sort of financial assistance.
>> Did she say that? Was that in the post that she was
getting paid? Did she disclose that months ago? She was >> She
didn't disclose that she was being paid months ago. No, that's
just a lie. That is a lie. This guy just loves lying. This soy
pill guy just lies all the time. That's what I think we actually
have to do now is I want to go through like Hutch's Twitter from
the when this initially broke and just cover the lies, right?
Like actually like message him and just be like, "Hey, I notic
you like lied a lot." or just do like a big tweet thread of like
this is how Hutch's narrative shifted over time based on like
the best argument somebody had told him at any given moment.
This guy is like a goldfish, okay? He can't retain anything in
his brain. The last person who told him some shill point for
Chorus, he believes it 100%. I would love to do that. I I think
I think you you can do some like connecting of dots here because
like Brian Tyler Cohen when he announced the program he like
very much described what the program was going to be and >> that's
my tweet. Hold on. That's my tweet. You go look at this. Where's
BTC at? Where's that was BTC? >> Oh, not BTC. Hold on.
in the article that this is some arm of >> oh this is not
>> about growing the progressive I have been beating the
drum about growing the progressive media ecosystem for years
now we finally got an exciting update I'm part of a team of creators
that's created chorus media chorus is a creator-led group of
voices from the left coming together to scale up drive the conversation
online
wait drive the conversation online
drive the conversation in what way >> and try and rebalance
the massive disparity at play on the left and the right so here's
the Chorus is going to support left-wing creators in a bunch
of tangible ways. Funding editors and researchers and bookers,
helping creators who are established on one platform, make sure
they've got a presence on the others, and coordinating our messaging.
Oh, it's almost like that other part is really uh really important.
Also, for a lot of those like learnings, why wouldn't they just
open source those learnings for people, right? Leftwing nonpartisan.
True. Leftwing nonpartisan. >> Now, for me specifically,
I'm not going to accept any funding. that money needs to go to
new creators and the folks who can help them grow. But I'll be
focused on message coordination. It has felt for the last decade
like Republicans head into a morning meeting to get aligned on
messaging.
Wow. It's like Republicans get aligned on messaging in a morning
meeting. And I want Democrats to do that. I want Democratic messaging,
you know, like we're in a morning meeting. Yeah, I know. I know.
Yeah, Matt Slice, we can get to the the PV stuff later. Yeah,
I am aware. I'm aware. I I do want to cover that stuff, but we
have so much content, okay? So much content today that I need
more time. I need more subs. Okay, what do we What are we at
so far? Hold on. We need way more time on the stream. Okay, I
can't do it. I can't do it with just this much time. Wait, let
me reset subs before you guys donate. Guys, $45. It's It's We're
nine subs away from another hour on the stream. Let's get more
time on the stream. I think we need more time on the stream.
I'm trusting you guys. I think you can make it happen. Three
debate react. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep.
>> I think you guys are right that there was a like a secrecy
clause in terms of like receiving funds. Uh Soy Pill had already
conceded early earlier before we got bogged down in this entire
conversation that disclosure would have been better. But I'm
at the point now where I say like I'm totally on board with them
like not disclosing because of the reaction that we're seeing
like right now on
Listen, I'm totally when we were hiding this and nobody had any
idea that we were paying people, I was okay with them not disclosing.
Now that there's been a crazy reaction to this information,
I support them not disclosing still. I haven't changed my position
one even tiny little bit, actually.
>> Yeah. No, no. I I still don't want them to disclose
>> this panel. And then the larger reaction on social media.
It took about two seconds before people were accusing these people
of taking funds to stay silent on Gaza. So if these people want
to take those funds and not disclose it and they're not legally
obligated.
>> Yeah. [__] That's my arguing. >> Uh-oh.
Fabian has hit Hutch in the head with a baseball bat like four
times already. And he's hearing Hutch. He's like He's like, "Wait,
wait, wait. Hutch. Did Hutch get back up?" Oh, hold on. Hold
on. Did Hutch get back up? Let me get the bat back out. This
got to go down again. >> Did anybody in this panel make
Oh, you're just arguing with Twitter. >> No, no, no. He's
not arguing with >> Conversation. The larger conversation.
It was so obvious that these people were getting smeared like
right away. They were being accused of some of the most
>> that brain argument that happening. >> Hold on.
Let him finish his argument.
is a justification to tell these guys, hey, you know, maybe don't
disclose that you're taking these funds. Now, if you guys could
establish in any kind of material way that the funds, them taking
this money impacted their content at >> Hold on, POV. It's
uh Fabian Liberty running into Hutch. Okay. >> I mean,
do you even know who you're talking to? >> It's Fabian.
This is Hutch. This is the bald Hutch. >> Yo, what's up?
>> What's up? >> Do Do you have any idea? Any idea
who I
basically kind of a big deal.
>> Oh man, that's beautiful.
>> You listening? Okay. Grass grows, birds fly, sun shines,
and brother, I hurt
>> I'm a force in nature. B. If you were from where I was
from, you'd be dead.
>> Did is this Hush get back up? Time for another bunk.
>> Then you would have a leg to stand on. But there's no
indication that this was the case. you keep rational argument
like you know maybe don't disclose that >> there's there's
no way hold on what there's no way Hutch turned back into a robot
and did the same thing again right I just want to make sure that
didn't >> is a justification to tell these guys
taking these fun now if you guys could establish in any kind
of material way that the funds them taking this money impacted
their content at all then you would have a leg to stand on but
there's no indication that this was the case you >> refuse
rational arguments and you keep arguing with Twitter and >> stuff.
You got Yeah, you got to
>> Twitter leftists are really mean to me. So, I think
uh you shouldn't have to disclose funding at all cuz Twitter
leftists are mean. They're real mean. >> Burberry argument
here, right? You're saying, "Oh, okay. So, uh because uh there
was a a strong reaction the other way. Um you can sacrifice these
principles. You can be dishonest like like what nonsense is that?"
So, like um >> Strong doesn't even begin to cover it. Take
a look at their mentions. >> The reason why
>> what what are their mentions? Hold on. What are their
mentions?
I need I need Hutch not to virtue signal. Bring screenshots.
Bring screenshots and bring a lot of screenshots. Okay. Don't
bring me one or two with like like three likes on them. Okay.
Bring me a lot of mentions.
>> Reason why that we're seeing the backlash we're seeing
now is because there wasn't the the the transparency in the first
place. If this had been clear from the very start, we wouldn't
be having this issue at all. At all. Um, so >> just a just
a just a a little note on >> I heard I heard that some
Twitter lefties emailed Hutch pictures of Skulls. Okay, I heard
it. I heard that and it's just disgusting. Okay, this man has
a family. This man has a family. >> That um I disclosed
about progressive victory and I was very open about it and I
had that issue. So it didn't fix it. Oh, it's almost like Wick
just count just disproved the argument he's clearly on the side
of. Hey, did Taylor Loren write an article on progressive victory?
No. And you still get called shills? Oh, it's almost like people
have a principal position against taking money from like political
orgs that seem to be on a certain bend that's against them.
And also that like some lefties, okay, I'm looking at Hassan.
I'm looking at bad empanadas specifically. Okay, I'm looking
at Bad Empanad specifically. Some of them will just lie to achieve
whatever end they think they can. Some of them have the morals
of Destiny's podcast co-host, former podcast co-host Dan Saltman.
Okay, they'll just say whatever they can to get whatever they
can to get whatever they want accomplished. Okay, they'll just
lie. They'll just lie and say you're being paid to show for Israel.
They don't know that you're being paid to show for Israel. They
have no proof of it, but they think you show for Israel and they'll
say you're paid to show for Israel. Yeah, that's how that goes.
They're liars.
But they don't need an article from Taylor Loren to lie. They
would have lied anyway.
They just would have lied. That's like what they want to do.
>> Even if you're at least >> Yeah. They're a progressive
victory people who disclose their entire
and are now being doxed at their homes because of just aligning
with someone that is politically antithetical to someone >> Didn't
doxed at their homes. I That might be true. I think some people
did get apparently there's like a zip code you could have leaked
that is quite bad that is like um is basically gives you like
your street more or less right if you have like the longer version
of a zip code apparently can give your street potentially so
that would be pretty rough that'd be a lot is Dan still saying
his son's 45 I don't know >> I'm not looking at it so like
like there wouldn't have been >> oh but sorry that suffice
to say though or sorry uh it it would be really bad to have that
docks. But I think most of those people what they had docs was
the uh like it was like name or name and state like we'll get
into it cuz I I need to look at the specifics before I say but
I've seen a lot of indications that like Hutch basically only
had information exposed that he publishes online in multiple
places that he's never wanted taken down, never expo expressed
any discomfort with being online. Now, if people say Hutch's
like name and state while harassing him, if he publicly discloses
those openly and attaches them to his uh Yeah, I know Dylan was
I know Dylan I wasn't going to say Dylan, but I know Dylan was
I'm saying um I'm saying for Hutch if if it was just his name
and state and he openly like publishes those and talks about
it, I don't I don't know if he got docked. He he he just got
harassed right by Badam Padata. >> I I don't think there'd
be an article. Um, I don't think there would be >> like
Oh man, how do I put it? You can collect personal if if it was
his like address and he threw the open I man it's like right
on the line because it is personal information like collected
for the purpose of for like harassing him. So it's like it's
almost being the definition. I just feel like probably your full
name when you use your name and your gaming name and like you
have multiple websites that say your full name that you publish
this information together like that's that's ah man >> oh
actually there might be an article uh discussing um like the
whole like structure of their >> be a big deal though >> yeah
I think it would be far less of a big deal um I worked for progressive
victory as well uh previously um I disclosed everything I didn't
have a problem but I can't speak to anyone else's uh experiences
So I I'll give you
would you recognize >> like sorry recognize what >> the
the fact like what Wick said >> is that why intent with
doxing matters um yeah it does matter but like if Dylan like
technically
here's the question if I call Dylan Burns in a video where I
want him har in a video where like I am very very angry at him
I'm criticizing him I'm borderline harassing him if I call him
Dylan Burns Well, Dylan Burns is technically
like uh personally identifiable information and I am trying to
harass him in some way. Am I doxing him when his name is Dylan
Burns? Obvious answer to me appears to be no.
Said is so relevant cuz like what's happening right now is like
PV is getting wrapped up in all this as well. And we have Hassan
[__] along with other like enormous lefty creators
that are going on their stream and just flippantly accu accusing
PB of being a Destiny slush fund that was paid to do Israeli
propaganda.
Now I will I will just point out okay
well that sucks. Well that sucks for you Hutch. Okay. Unfortunately
the problem you run into
is that this this Destiny guy is doing you no favors. Okay. Hold
on. Let me let me pull a screenshot.
This this Destiny guy's kind of guys over. I don't know. Do you
guys like as much as I know PV is not that? Why is Destiny telling
people that Pavey is that, right? Isn't that weird? That feels
weird to me. So, he's complaining about people distancing from
him in March.
Like the entire progressive victory paid out millions in wages
to all of these people and the whole thing only existed because
of me on top of a billion other things. Like I is this not making
its way how did this not make its way onto Twitter when when
people soy the out about being called the Destiny slush fund
which I I don't believe it was. I'm just laughing that like Destiny's
out here saying it cuz all these people abandoned me after I
got them all this money for nothing just cuz I'm a great guy.
I totally didn't expect anything in return. And I can't really
say why I'm really mad right now but these people. Oh, Destiny
did say he had no formal involvement with Pavey. He literally
had formal involvement with PB. He literally coordinated with
PV. He literally got a meeting with Roka. He almost got a meeting
with Joe Biden by formally coordinating with PV. This is [__]
crazy.
Sorry, that's a quote from his stream or some [__]
>> my mentions are [__] like nuclear like a
nuclear like a >> I said
just took
I want to play a game. Drive the conversation. Win 8,000 dark
dollars. Stay silent and you quit streaming to become a mod in
Hutch's chat. I make. No. No. Not worth it.
No. Not worth it. Not worth it. But thank you for the donation.
Brian Tyler Cohen. I think we're six subs away, guys, for another
hour on the stream. We got three $5 donos. Six subs or $30 away
from another hour on the stream. Go ahead. Fill up the meters.
Fill them up. Fill them up. >> But the problem is, for
example, we're talking about the doxing, right? So that was an
issue made by a filing that
[__] YouTube video. This is a debate. >> Why
are you like this is drama slot [__] that you're
always
the reason why the progressive victory filings got used for doxing
was because there was a misfittered
with horrible bad actors
these insane baseless claims. So would you could you not understand
that >> insane baseless claims? Well if they're making
baseless claims you actual [__] If they're totally
baseless, why are you worried about people providing them a
Why are you worried about the basis being Taylor Lorenz's article
when they're reading it totally disingenuously and just saying
whatever baseless [__] they wanted to say anyway?
Do you understand how that's a totally moronic standard that
you should never try to hold people to, right? No, he's talking
about like bad empanada calling him a a Destiny Israel shill.
That's what he's talking about. Tequila Sunset. But but the whole
point of that is there was no basis for that. They're going to
make baseless claims. They're going to call you an Israel shill.
No matter who you're getting paid by, no matter what you're tied
to, if you shill for Israel, they're going to say, "You get paid
to shill for Israel." Right? That's just going to be their baseline
position. They're going to lie. They're going to say whatever
they have to to make that point over and over and over again.
Maybe that kind of >> that wouldn't that wouldn't change
with disclosure is my point. So, I'm I'm addressing what you're
saying just in case you think I'm like distracted or trying to
shout over. >> It's not changing with disclosure.
>> we disclosed, bro. >> So, Progressive Victory
disclosed not just people's full names, also their zip codes,
right? That's not the kind of disclosure anybody is trying to
>> They gave it to the FC as a legal >> Yeah, exactly.
They disclosed it to the FC on a public filing by >> what?
No, what I think what happened was they paid people out of the
out of a incorrect account and then because they paid them from
c some certain part of their business accidentally, they had
to publicly file all the payments they made. So I think they
must have paid them through the actual the actual transparent
part of their pack and they're supposed to do it through the
LLC. They did it through the transparent part of the pack and
then they're like, "Oh, now we have to file with the FCC that
we paid out of this pack." And then hold on because I know about
what happened here. And then people and I know who did it too.
I know there was a se several people who did it went found it
and publish that all over Twitter and things like that in order
to harass and docks. That was the point of not the not PV giving
it to the FEC but for the people who found the FC listings and
posted everyone's address and full name and zip code. >> Um
Rob J. Hammond. people who get doxed around this stuff around
like uh it's not it's not people who are like um being targeted
by anti- Destiny people. That's not what happens. It's like specifically
people Destiny is like leaning on and and talking to. It's all
around Destiny. It's people totally obsessed with Destiny. Um
in the Kiwi Farms case in in the Willy Mack case, I actually
don't know between the Bad Empanada group or the anti like the
the Kiwi Farm Destiny's Kiwi Farms thread. I don't know which
one really like I know where it originated but I don't know if
like it was a an anonymous account that was made days before
right so I don't know if that was like a guy who's a part of
I I don't know what community they were a part of yeah
>> but I could easily see it being that bad and put out
a community too that would have happened with or without disclosure
right and that would would happen with or without an attachment
to an organization right politics unfortunately politics online
is incredibly like toxic >> like and they they keep using
PB is an example that just proves this out. You didn't get a
Taylor Loren article for
You didn't get that and everybody still accused him of shilling.
Everybody still accused him of being bot >> flavor of content.
If your address is out there on a public listing and people find
it, they will post it if they disagree with you. >> Prime
has nothing to do with anything,
which you would only know if you're >> You do not need
to get paid by an organization to get >> Go ahead, Rald,
please. >> Prime said that this would probably dis disappear.
He said there would probably be an article, but people wouldn't
be mad if they if they had just disclosed up front. I think I
mean I think the progressive victory thing is an exact example
of how that wouldn't happen. Disclosure doesn't really have any
like you said >> up front.
>> Who? Yeah. All of us did. All the creators in the program.
>> That's not true.
That's literally not true. Hutch. That's not true. >> All
the all the creators in the program. We were all disclosing.
I was disclosing on my stream. Wick. You're not even a single
panel. I'm just Yeah, I'm just >> Wick was not disclosing
at every single panel until it came up until it was turned into
a [__] issue. Wick was not disclosing it. Kilo video
still exists, right? Well, you just go watch the Kilo video.
Here, I'll go find it. One second. I'm not going to watch it
right now, but I'll put it in the chat. Oh, that's it's Kilo's
Twitter. Kilotonics YouTube. YouTube. No. Kilotonix.
God damn it. Oh, that. Okay, never mind. Progressive victory.
>> Easy way to >> in the dark. Oh god, why was wait
why was food chops involved in this? What this became not about
the self harm of reinforcing a negative part of your brain but
about outward normalization? >> Hesitant about food chops
versus vos is whether or not I feel like there's an attempt to
normalize. >> And notice Brianna Woo nodding her head in
agreement with counterpoints. She also refuses to be platformed
with food shops. But Brianna Woo actually has no idea what her
reason for this is. My objection of food shops is not that God
Brianna Woos like just the worst. Just the absolute worst that
>> she jacks off to Lai. >> Oh, right. So Vos hypocrisy.
Yes. So basically that these people would they they would have
stated principal position against positions against being around
people who jerk off the loi. But then Vos was found to be off
the wall and they're all like, "Ah, what are you going to do?
We need to win. We we need Joe Biden elected."
Right? They wouldn't get platform with food shops. And then
they totally defended Bosage.
So the principal didn't exist. >> My objection to food
shops is she's a drama farmer. >> Briana must be confused
because at the end of this very stream she plugs her new show
with counterpoints saying this >> uh Counterfire like Connor
and I are starting that uh this week. My whole theory with this
is I love drama content but I
she's the biggest she's the biggest
on planet Earth. She's like the dumbest human being on planet
Earth. It's insane. Okay. I
me Okay. Anyway, that Oh, I meant to pull that up for the link
>> link in the in the chat and show the kilo thing cuz
he explains exactly when people disclose how they disclose and
who is like actually doing it before they were required to or
before they were getting pressured to. So, cool. Cool. Cool.
>> And I >> short maybe
and to be clear to be clear PV. No, I'm not watching that right
now. I've watched on the reason why like the address got out
there. That was >> so disclosure is completely irrelevant
to any I've watched it like supposed to be a part of the FC filing.
But the point is is that you can disclose you can do everything
right. You can be completely upfront about the work that you're
doing and the badass
behind this and they're still going to accuse you involvement
in
the mechanism. Okay, I'm addressing what is fine. The the the
mechanism through you getting your information out there was
progressive victory. That's true. In terms of people going ahead
and then doxing you, it's got nothing to do with PV. You're a
political creator who a lot of people on the bottom left.
>> This is This is pretty funny because uh because of the
PV tweets. This is pretty >> I don't want to go to the
PV tweets yet,
>> it's it's hate. Exactly. It's irrelevant. That's my
entire point. >> Stickers stickers. the point that they're
making that Prime was making and Prime said as Renald said that
the harassment and the the crazy would stop if they just disclosed
and the only reason we're bringing up the progressive victory
is because that is evidence that at least in progressive victories
case that didn't seem to help. That's the only being made here.
>> So realistically any real any >> Let's give it
back to Prime. Prime prime >> Sure. Sure. Um and I'd like
to hear what you have to say Renald. I don't mean to like talk
over you. Um but um yeah, so to be clear uh I didn't I never
knew that people's uh were doxed in this PB week. This is actually
news to me. Um here um but um I think that when I say
my national she's breaking up. He's breaking up. Uh we'll get
to it when we get to it. MD7401.
Sorry. >> I know it's within my my circle. My my my talking
about this a lot. Um it's making waves online. Um but but in
any case I don't think that um most of uh this dialogue would
have happened if people their audiences right the way I found
out about this is through David Pacman actually right so I didn't
have read the article immediately pack made a response to the
article I saw that uh video first um and I thought like you know
without having read the article that what he was saying was reasonable
um and uh like yeah like I it seemed so inferious to me um I
went to his comment section people were accusing him of all kinds
of crazy [__] guess what this is the internet they
do it all the goddamn time that's going to happen Right. U I
appreciate what Scott was saying. Like are you arguing with Twitter?
Yeah. They're going to say, >> "Bro, if you're if you're
picking content online, especially any kind of contentious content,
you're going to get like you're get called out by insane people.
It's just going to happen, right? Like obviously to some extent
you have to be willing to accept that. If you're going to make
political content online, yeah, people are going to accuse you
of getting paid and with zero >> Craziness uh to you. People
were saying about David Pacman, "Oh, I guess that's why he doesn't
um mention Gaza." like first of all doesn't make any sense because
uh the DNC is uh in favor of Israel back completely right so
he'd be incentivized to talk about Gaza one way the other right
um in favor of the IDF um but uh secondly no that's obviously
>> slice no many of them did not disclose or did not disclose
effectively which Wick's point about disclosing was he said I
believe on a AMA stream with like 50 viewers on it I think one
time about four months before he started getting money from PV
no four months sorry not four month four months before he actually
got called out for it. I believe he said, "Guys, I'm going to
be working with PB at some point in the future or I'm going to
be I'm I'm starting to work with this company called Pavey."
So, he did technically disclose it on one stream that was like
an AMA stream, not a debate stream, right? Am I Am I getting
this correct? I think I'm getting this 100% correct, but I'm
not I'm not I think I'm like 90 I'm 99% sure
that uh that like there was a few months that went by and then
he like actually disclosed it and was like disclosing it consistently.
Kilo, if you're here, just explain. Just say if I'm correct.
Don't just say I'm going to say this. Just correct me on whatever
I just whatever I just said. You're the guy who wrote the video.
You know, you know the timeline. >> I was completely
>> I'm pretty sure I'm 100% correct here. 90% of the time
it works 100% of the
>> Argument because um uh the gods situation has been happening
for nearly >> Am I talking about Wick? Yeah, I'm saying
I think Wick disclosed on like some little AMA stream at some
point, right?
He disclosed that he's going to work with PV, but it was not
like a broad disclosure and then he tried to bring that up later
as if like, oh, I totally disclosed this, right? And people are
like, you disclose it to like 50 viewers on an AMA stream. That's
kind >> two years. Uh, this um incubator program is brand
new. And I think the most likely answer is that um uh Pac-Man
is >> Oh, so he brought it. So he he disclosed
in the context of already being called
Zionist who understands his views are unpopular and just not
going to talk about it. That's the reason why um he hasn't said
anything. Um but even then still people took that opportunity
um uh in this moment of uh friction of contention to put that
out there. Oh now I see right there must be something shadowy
about that. I get that that happened right? But like the the
way to help mitigate that I'll say this instead, right? Rather
than stop completely. The way to help mitigate that is always
just be upfront with your your connections, right? especially
your financial connections and then you know you have to let
the chips fall within >> I mean doesn't it speak directly
against the fact that disclosure would have helped it that people
are accusing David Pacman of taking money from Apac when I mean
nothing like that ever got disclosed they're just making that
up so
>> make the point >> dude bad bad empanada makes
up all the time with zero basis he just lies if you want people
to not say things that could be used by bat and panata as an
as like as what he claims to be a basis for their lies is that
you just want people not to talk. That guy will say anything
based on anything. And while sometimes it can be funny, a lot
of the times it's just like whatever. Yeah, you just can't talk.
That guy will lie no matter what. >> This opportunity.
But no, but but specifically the reason the thing I was responding
to was hut specifically. Hey, the reason now I'm against disclosing
because I see this reaction. That's what I originally responded
to, right? That's crazy, right? Because
because facto, right? after after the fact I see craziness online,
I'd say no, we shouldn't have principal transparency. That's
not >> I don't you can you just start dismissing like doxing
and massive amounts of harassment. It's like, oh, that just happens
on the internet. Like if you're a small Hold on. If you're a
small creator, that was so full of [__] Hold on.
Hold on. >> Did this Did this just get up again?
>> Did he just Did he just get up again? There's no way
he just got up again. I hurt people.
>> I'm a force of nature. >> If you were from where
I was from, you'd be [__] dead. A w
sorry I should have Christ if you're a small creator they >> this
this got up again. Let me get this bat back out. Oh boy. Am I
going to am I really going to have to get this bat back out again?
God
forgive me for what I must do.
God forgive Fabian Liberty for what he must do this day. >> Hold
on. If you're a small creator that was so full of [__]
let Hutch finish. Let Hutch finish. >> [__]
Christ. If you're a small creator that gets picked for this incubator
program, you don't have like a big following. You're not used
to that level of attention. You're certainly not used to that
level of harassment, doxing. So whether or not like listen, I'm
sympathetic to arguments that people should overdisclose. I think
that's like generally good practices. However, I understand the
idea to protect smaller creators from that level of harassment
that you guys are just kind of just like or you know that just
happens on the funny thing is is most of the Tik Tok creators
who make the same argument are like, "Yeah, we're in red states.
We we're scared of Republicans." Hutch is like, "I'm scared of
leftists. I'm scared of socialists. Socialists are like the scariest
people on the internet. Meanwhile, you go to like the socialist
the DSA meeting. Is it is it a DSA meeting where they do the
jazz hands instead of clapping? Like guys, there are some people
here who have sensory sensitivities. So, we don't clap. We do
jazz hands. Jazz hands. It's not a small >> These are the
people who fill Hutch's nightmares. Okay. Hutch wakes up first
thing in the morning in the middle of the night and thinks, "Did
they shake their hands again? Did they do the jazz hands again?"
Oh, no. They did the jazz hands again.
Have you responded to a single argument this entire panel? >> Are
can you hear me? Is my mic on? I'm >> My friend, have you
Can you even hear us right now? >> What you just said?
>> No, you're not. I don't think you know what an argument.
Do you know what an argument is? >> Are you not? What?
>> Oh, they do snap, don't they? They do snap. They don't
just do jazz hats. >> I'm responding.
Good practices. However, I understand the idea to protect smaller
creators from that level of harassment that you guys are just
kind of just like or it just happens on the internet. That's
not >> So they've been saying that like hey when you do
political content like this could happen anyway. Just because
somebody did an expose on you does not mean they're exposing
you to being doxed or harassed. >> Small thing.
>> Have you responded to a single argument this entire
can you hear me? Is my mic on? I'm responding exactly to what
you just said. >> No you're not. I don't think you know
an argument. Can you do you know what an argument is? >> I
responded precisely to exactly what he just said. Every single
person shakes their head. Sorry. Every single person being dickers
in prime just in unison. >> Put my mic on. I'm responding
exactly to what he just said. No, you're not. I don't think you
know what an argument can even Do you know what an argument?
>> They're both They're both shaking their >> What
are you not What are you not >> Do you know what an argument
is? I'm just curious. >> I am making the argument that
the response that we're seeing an argument >> Can you shut
the [__] up for 5 seconds? Seriously, I'm making
the argument that the what we're seeing right now with the crazy
level of harass >> Sir,
do you know what an argument is? Sir, sir >> is the reason
why they would have that kind of a protection mechanism in the
in the in the contract.
>> That is not why they have that protection mechanism
in the contract. And Hutch knows this. This is like the This
is the completely stupid argument. You You are like This is the
shill argument. Okay. If you were just a total shill, this is
the argument you'd make, right? Oh, uh well,
trans black creators in red states are going to be under threat
if you if you if they disclose. Brain damaged. Okay. The whole
thing with the disclosure stuff, the reason they have that language
in the contract is to avoid problems with the FC, problems with
their charity classification, right? >> You understand?
You guys are making the case that like, oh yeah, >> do
you know what an argument is? >> You guys are making the
case that disclosing would have fixed all that. Obviously not.
You're
>> no one know that argument, but do you know what an argument
is? >> It's a damn near
I want to hear from Prime. Prime, >> It's a damn near knows
what an argument >> No, he doesn't know what an argument
is. Let's move on. Okay, we're good. >> It is a damn near
non-secular to insert like, oh, you aren't going to protect him
from doxing. Doxing going to have I talk about transparency.
I talk about, hey, um, you should, you know, talk about your
financial relationship, right? Just like you do with any other,
um, uh, sponsorship that you get, right? Um, if you got something
from, uh, you know, uh, Amazon.com or something and you you got
you got cut a check, then you should do an ad read and let them
know. I wonder if the I wonder if the FTC would take this. Okay.
Yeah, I realize I realize that Raid: Shadow Legends sponsored
me, but if I disclose that it was sponsored, I really think somebody
would hurt me. I think somebody would hurt me. I don't think
I should follow the law. I think somebody would hurt me. >> This
is a section, right? >> This is like finally go for what
I'm trying to say, which is like what is over me, please. >> I
prime and then we'll get to then >> Yeah. So to go from
like talking about we should have a principal transparency say
oh well if you are transparent then you'll get docks then get
docks. No, I'm sorry. Happens, right? It's really unfortunate.
Again, I'm just hearing about this. But that's really unfortunate.
That's a misfiling from what I'm hearing from Dickers and all
the rest, right? That seems like a a misfiling. But to say that
oh from there right it follows that like because you are transparent
you're probably going to get dogs and that is the reason we have
to hide our our financial entanglements. That's nonsense. That's
a nonseative. >> I wonder the idea is that there are people
in this program who have zero online presence because they're
part of an incubator that may or may not not want to be immediately
public. >> Um if there's people in this incubator have
zero online presence that how I I'm
I I just had Okay. This is the shock I'm experiencing is similar
to the full body shock we all experienced when we saw Z Cohen's
chin for the first time. Okay. Z Cohen Sanchez's chin for the
first time. Full body shock. I just got shocked. Okay. What the
did he just say?
There there are people in this influencer incubator program who
have zero online presence.
I hope not. That would seem really really really dumb. That wouldn't
make any sense at all before they get expanded. And if you're
a figure and in your contract, it's like, hey, don't just go
in public and say, oh yeah, K, he's part of that. Oh, Hutch,
he's part of this. Yeah, he's getting money from them.
I'm not asking. >> Hold on. You got to finish responding.
no, no. I know you're not saying because course is not I'm not
saying course should necessarily like publish a list. I'm saying
the creator should publish. So the creator will be saying it
wouldn't give them more attention, right? If on my five um viewer
channel I say, "Oh, I'm working with Corors. That doesn't make
me six viewers, right? It doesn't do anything. So that would
be of course put that uh publish a list on their site and I'm
not even asking for >> Also the idea that these are like
tiny creators with no presence online just isn't true. In the
reporting that Ted Loren did these people have combined like
millions of followers online. >> Okay now think the biggest
being paid the most were the big followers. How many people have
these are the part?
>> How did they get found to get supported if they have
no presence? Actually give me the name of those people. Those
are the people who like two years from now are going to have
like 10 million followers. Those are the made guys. Those are
the actual guys I need to keep an eye on. Anybody who had zero
followers, zero online presence before they entered this incubator
program, give me their
names now. Okay, I need those names. Those people are just totally
madeup manufacturer guys. You serious? They have no presence
online and they're an influence. They're in an influencer incubator
program. Isn't that insulting to everybody who's made Democrat-
centered content? Okay. Progressive centered content up to this
point. We're actually going to hire some people who don't even
do this yet.
Just for fun. We're gonna see. Okay. Just doing it for fun. >> Incubators.
People trying to get into streaming who are like are not doing
anything. They need to expand their reach. This is a wide range.
Some people are being paid $8,000 a month and some people didn't
get shipped or offered like 100
bought into this campaign. >> There's somebody who was
in the 250 tier. Hold on. I could have sworn there was somebody
who's in the 250 tier.
Dark money. Dark money.
We had somebody who was in the 250 tier here. Maybe they didn't
get named. I thought we'd heard from somebody who was getting
the lowest amount, but maybe not. I only see one instance of
250 here. Oh, maybe not. They were anonymous. Okay, then. Yeah,
never mind. Cuz I was just thinking if there if there was somebody,
it'd be cool if we could know who the smallest ones were.
>> have no online presence.
>> They re They're not saying no online presence. They're
saying neglig.
He said no online presence repeatedly, which was really
and indicative of his bias, right? He's going to be super hyperbolic
in that direction. >> Also confusing to be fair with some
people who literally have no online presence in a different program
that I might be a part of. So, excuse me. Now, I am allowed to
disclose that to be >> We don't know the vast majority.
>> The point is the point is my initial claim to go all
the way back. >> Dude, I'm just going to start I'm going
to start shilling super hard for Republicans and just like watch
the money flow in. Apparently, all these people get paid by everybody,
okay? All over the place. I just want I just want Can I get money,
guys? I can watch me pick this apart. I'll take money to not
criticize. For $5,000 a month, I will never mention one of these
Democrat dark money groups again. Maybe $8,000 a month. I'll
never mention it again. I'll encourage other people to mention
it or to not mention it. I'll I'll go like, "Wait, is that really
important? Do you really think that's important? Don't you think
that like there's technically like a fascist in the White House
right now? I know all of the shilling lines. Give me the money.
I'll just shill. Just give me the money. I'll do it right now.
>> There's We don't have to dwell on this too long, but
saying you are part of Chorus and saying you are part of an incubator
program are both Hey, I am disclosing that I
I'm disclosing that to you guys right now. Okay, I don't I like
care about this because people are like full of but realistically
like I'm not against chorus existing and I'm all for enriching
myself. So give me the money. I'm working with a fund whose mission
is to expand the reach of these people. Now >> no, I didn't
just do it for free. It's not my actual genuine position. So
you have to pay me a lot of money. All >> If you want to
say, hey, they have to disclose the exact amount of money, that's
a different story. If you want to say if they don't say it at
all, this is a completely different thing. Especially if they're
telling them what content to make. But when Alli or any of these
other people or Brian Tyler Cohen say, I'm working with Chorus.
You go on the Chorus website. Cororus says we're trying to use
the fund from all of your donations to expand the reach of these
people and you're now telling me there's a huge material difference
between connecting people with politicians and hey, I'm teaching
you how to expand your content through like digital means and
how to use these tools. I think this is in a complete >> Did
he just leave out the most important part which Dicker's got
and they're giving you money
massive amounts of money. >> How are we are we confused?
>> Insane distinction that does not matter. This is Chorus
and people saying and Chorus is helping me. >> There's
a very clear distinction there, right, between like just receiving
the support and like getting access to politicians and having
this newsroom and that's all cool and then actually receiving
money. >> Why why does the money in this specific thing
make a difference? >> Because you get
He tried it. He tried the IRI point. Guys, I just I don't really
think I I don't think you could pay me to change any of my opinions.
I think I think I'm totally immune to money. I think people are
just generally totally immune to money. Money doesn't change
their their decision-m at all. I I always think like in my head,
you have to be so insanely rich to believe this, right? This
is like the question, okay? This is exactly like the question.
How much money would it would would you need to suck a dick?
Right? Anybody who says you couldn't pay me to do that, they're
like, if there's ever a socialist revolution, they're the people
you could eat first, like safely. That's like the easiest question
to say, we just eat that guy,
right? Cuz anybody who's ever had to work to like pay bills and
like buy, you know what I mean? They've got a price that's way
lower than you would really think is way lower. >> Getting
some kind of like renumeration for the political you're doing.
>> We also don't know.
You think these people would be getting paid if they didn't post
any content? >> I have I'm going to get going to get a
thing from that. >> The point is
>> how much? Uh probably less than a million dollars. Huh?
Like easily less than a million dollars. But I'm not going to
go any further than that. >> If they stop posting content
like last next 3 months, you think there still be if you if the
point of the program is to expand left-wing content creators,
obviously if you didn't do content creation, they would run the
program.
>> point of the organization? Expanding the reach of leftwing
creators. That's the organization, not the program. The program
is more >> think the what's the point of the >> to
support small creators specifically to like get them training
subset of
>> Yeah, that's where the payments happen. >> I have
I have a different question. >> That's where the payments
happen which we care about. >> I do want to talk about
the anonymity subject because Hutch did bring up a new thing
where he didn't care if people >> Oops. By the way, it
would have to be one of those things where like you don't where
like nobody would know, right? Nobody would know about it. It'
just be you. Actually, here's another thing. Nobody knows about
it as through a glory hole. So the guy doesn't even know who
you are. Okay. Through a glory hole and nobody knows
that has to be like a low number, right? It can't be millions
of dollars. Even for millionaires, it can't be millions of dollars.
No, I've never s for money before. Signal. Jesus Christ. >> People
actually disclosed, right? Because there would be value to anonymity.
Um you uh Dickers, Prime Kai, and I think Fabian seemed to disagree
and you can correct me if I'm wrong if I' I've miscarried. >> I
was telling you I've worked. Okay. I've worked like minimum wage
jobs before and if you could save like 5,000 hours in a 5,000
hours in a minimum wage job. Okay, let's just be real. Just be
real. Be real for 2 seconds. You save 5,000 hours. Would you
suck a dick to live for 5,000 hours more? That's the question.
Okay. If you could live for 5,000 hours extra on your life,
just prime of your life more time to live, would you suck a dick?
answer has to be yes. Has to be yes. Come on. In that in that
exact nobody knows glory hole. You don't have to see the guy.
Come on, man. >> That but how far would you extend this
um want of transparency? Do you think that people should be required
to disclose how they vote?
>> What? No, that's completely >> No. Why? But why
shouldn't why is it why >> uh this is actually wrong.
You don't simply live to suck. You suck to live. you simply suck
to live for longer.
>> Is it bad that we protect the anonymity of someone who
votes of of how someone votes? >> Cuz voting is something
you do. This is a benefit that you're receiving. >> I mean,
there's so many there's so many distinctions like we could come
up with 100, right? >> I don't even I don't even
vote. Oh, this is Wick's right to vote point. Dude, Wick is I
I don't understand how Wick thought he cooked here. This was
like maybe the dumbest thing I uh I there's so many dumb things.
It's hard to pick. But this was this was so bad.
Guys, should why shouldn't we disclose who we vote for? Hey guys,
why shouldn't we disclose who we vote for? >> Right. Because
there would be value to anonymity. Um you uh Dickers, Prime Kai,
and I think Fabian seem to disagree.
So this is because the I guess what would you say like the positive
utility the net utility of disclosing who you vote is lower than
hiding it, right? So it would be nice to know who everybody voted
for maybe. But the problem is is then you get a lot of like possible
social pushing towards a certain ideological like bend or something,
right? You could be menaced into actually voting differently.
with these people. They are literally it's like they're voting
every day and other people vote based on their vote. It's like
there's some net utility there that they should be disclosing.
They should be above reproach on these kinds of things. I haven't
thought about it too much, but just the idea that like oh, also
you're being paid to do it. You're being paid. You're like being
paid. Uh the likelihood of the money changing your your opinion
is way higher than random other people cuz other people you're
putting your opinion out there in the public already. Yeah. I
don't know. It's way higher based on the the money you're receiving.
>> And you can correct me if I'm wrong if I' I've mischaracterized
that, but how far would you extend this um want of transparency?
Do you think that people should be required to disclose how they
>> You should be required to disclose things that are a
conflict of interest, a potential conflict of interest that like
support you financially.
Um and you have like some actually negotiated obligation. So,
you've signed a contract that says you're going to get paid and
possibly that could affect what you're what you're doing, right?
Like, for example, if it was a doctor and they were being paid
to go to conferences by opiate companies, I would want to know
that because then if they prescribe opiates to me over a broken
leg, I might go, "Hey, wait, that's weird. Why are you giving
me heroin for my broken leg? I want pain meds, but I want [__]
heroin. That's scary. [__] that." >> What?
No, that's completely >> Why? Well, why shouldn't why is
it why is it bad that we protect the anonymity of someone who
votes?
>> Am I going to be hurt by believing somebody voted Republican
when they voted Democrat? No. Am I going to be hurt by believing
that my doctor is prescribing me the best thing for me when they
might be getting paid to prescribe me something else? Yes. Am
I going to be hurt by somebody who's giving a political opinion,
giving me a disingenuous political opinion because they're being
paid? Possibly. Yes. Five B. Hey, bro. >> There we go.
That's the That's the >> Stitching on chorus ain't the
move, fam. Stay in your lane before you get put on game. Know
what I'm saying? Be quiet. >> Thank you, Prime Kai. That
is an incredibly racist donation to make him have a black voice
and do like rhyming and but thank you. Thank you for the five,
guys. We are five subs away from another hour on the stream.
Got to get hours in to continue covering stuff, okay? Please
donate, donate, donate. It's really important. Give subs. Give
subs, buy more TTS messages, okay? Get more money in. We need
more time of how someone votes >> because voting is something
you do. This is a benefit that you're receiving. >> I mean,
there's so many there's so many distinctions like we could come
up with 100, right? >> I don't even I don't even >> How
is the right to vote you >> in doing crimes? Maybe. >> Hold
on. Right. We understand that not just money can influence us.
Correct.
>> This is who I explain the distinction. If Hold on. Stop.
Stop. If I'm dating someone who is a Republican, okay, she's
really hot, okay, and she just happens to be Republican.
The Destiny Lauren Southern
Impressive Gambit Wick. Let's see if it pays off. All by the
way, that one is more ambiguous. It's about what is the negative
utility of that. Like it's your personal
Oh, man. That one that one you could make arguments on, right?
That you could make arguments. to does that >> I think
that would be that would be unduly kind of incisive into your
personal life if you had to give away like personal relationships
you had yeah
>> be unduly I'm just asking why you're why you're drawing
the line on money >> because you're rece there's a there's
a quid proquo right there's a meeting of the minds there's a
contract sign right that that's that's probably journalist >> okay
unfortunately Willie made content about it okay so I can make
the joke how unethical was it for Willie to not disclose his
IDF bride okay while relentlessly shilling for Israel on the
internet while relentlessly attacking the sons of Palestine.
How unethical was this answer? Obviously a 10 on a 10-point scale.
Okay. A massive
>> Often times like um uh talk about their personal entanglements
with um like hey I like uh this person was the best man at my
wedding. I don't know. And I'm doing an article on their like
organization. I think people like do talk about their personal
entanglements. Yeah. So listen, there's there's two types of
influence, right? You have the general influence that you're
discussing and then you have undue influence. I don't think anyone
here is alleging like a English common law level of like undue
influence, right? Undo influence might be if they Yeah, Cranial
Kesh. Yeah, exactly. Um it's actually really difficult to express
or articulate how there would be a conflict there because of
your wife, right? And it's like something like romantic entanglements
are something we don't tend to like judge super harshly. We have
like a lot of letting that go. Money is just money. Money is
just like I'm literally trying to play on your greed. I'm playing
on like uh nothing intangible. Nothing intangible to the human
spirit, right? But with romance and like that, it's like it's
intangible. It's like very difficult to exactly figure out where
the line should be. Like that's a hard
>> Signed a 12-year contract that says you must do this
and then if you break the contract, you owe them $60,000 or something,
right? Like you might be able to argue undue influence here.
And I agree with you, right? If you had a Republican girlfriend,
that would influence you. or if you were, you know, able to join
some creator program that was specifically designed to fight
liberalism like progressive victory, but it gained you like a
bunch of opportunities with other streamers and got your name
out there that would influence you against the presumption of
like being for liberalism because progressive victory was against
it could. It does not necessarily have to. >> I guess the
fundamental question is this might cut the chase. Well, we can
cut the chase interrupt. I know you want >> Yeah, because
you talk for a long time and this will cut the chase and we'll
make it so much simpler. Why do you think the secrecy clause
was there?
>> Why do I think the secrecy clause was >> Because
the implication of the article is that we want you to be authentic,
but we don't want you to let other people know that you're paid.
Right? That is the implication of the article. Would you disagree
with that? >> I think trying to read into the implication
as opposed to the actual words gets a little difficult. But isn't
that the whole conversation is you are implying that because
there's money that isn't being disclosed there the implication
is that we can't trust what they're saying and that there's >> no
I was trying to explain I I was trying to explain right why there's
a distinction with being paid by a program is the distinction
here is listen if if I'm a content creator that's not getting
paid everyone recognizes that there's all kinds of influence
in my life everyone knows that I might be influenced by my mom's
opinion >> soy pill is doing the counterpoints play here
like what counterpoints dude
Man, there's just so many reasons to be annoyed with this counterpoints
guy. I sometimes I forget about that Pisco Destiny counterpoints
panel where counterpoints just did like some kind of like it
was the hope the homeless the the homeless jerker on the subway
like trying to get everybody's attention,
right? Like Pisco would start making a point and Counterpoints
would get up and start off, you know? God, that was so that's
so gross. So weird. >> I might be influenced by the place
I live. I might be influenced at the audience that I have when
you secret that you are getting paid that there's a there's a
fraudulent element not necessarily legally fraud but there is
a fraudulent element in that you gained your clout you gained
your followers you gained your influence and all of these opinions
are based upon the hard work that you put in to your channel
by yourself because there's because no one knows that oh I don't
know maybe you did maybe you didn't get potted by some wait
perfectly there's this whole right >> like okay so if you
say chorus helps me out and you don't say anything about money.
Would that dispel the notion that you've done this all on your
own? >> Yeah, I mean it would dispel the notion that you've
done it all on your own if you if you say I am a part of chorus
>> or like specifically like I've said in the past
he said he would vore Queen which un which spun unholy art. I
think he said he would eat Queman to be fair which kind of implies
chewing. All right. Queen was kind of intact totally intact in
his stomach. That was a little >> I haven't disclosed the
exact amount. >> Like somebody else added the vore thing.
Somebody else added their fetish to that. Okay. Was it Rise?
It was probably Risac. Ris's kind of a you you go look at Risac's
like history on his Twitter. Guy's an obvious guy was an obvious
just like Queman by the way. Quan obviously
I believe um he was watching Anavore content in 2019 Queen was
2019 2020 maybe 2021
he's watching Anavore content and his his DG logs literally say
I can fix her
emote. Okay, he doesn't want you to know this, but I'll always
tell the truth. Okay, cuz no matter how much Israel pays me,
I'm not defending every